this episode is brought to you by
element that's spelled lmnt
what is element it's a delicious
sugar-free electrolyte drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this stuff i have an entire shelf in my
garage full of
these boxes and i usually use one to two
per day element is formulated to help
anyone with their electrolyte needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following a keto low-carb or paleo diet
if you've ever struggled
to feel good on these diets it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming some electrolytes
you may not be getting enough
electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger
cramps headaches tiredness dizziness
this is where element can really help
and now with the winter months ahead of
us it's important to know that sweat
evaporates much more quickly in cold dry
weather
misleading our bodies into thinking that
we aren't losing fluids and electrolytes
as a result our thirst response can
decrease up to 40 percent
this response means that our kidneys
don't receive the signals they need from
hormones to conserve
water instead causing our urine
production to increase electrolytes are
crucial to supporting anti-diuretic
hormone
adh also known as vasopressin vaso
this hormone helps us to get through the
night with minimal
and the fewest number of bathroom breaks
improving sleep quality going to sleep
dehydrated
is a recipe for poor sleep quality to
make it easier for you guys to stay
hydrated in the winter
element has developed a versatile new
flavor chocolate salt chocolate salt can
be enjoyed cool
like elements other tasty flavors citrus
salt is probably my favorite
but it's especially delicious when
served hot weather with water or even
milk
just like you would with a cup of hot
cocoa or tea i like adding it to my
coffee in the morning so i have a small
amount of cream could be coconut cream
could be some other type of cream
coffee and then i'll add in the element
usually to
at least 16 to 20 ounces of coffee
so that's a good amount that i can kind
of sip on throughout the morning
sugar artificial ingredients coloring
all that nonsense are unhealthy and
unneeded there's none of that stuff in
element who uses element
here just a few three navy seal teams as
prescribed by their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl
teams have subscriptions as well as many
nba players and coaches
element is the executive hydration
partner of team usa weightlifting and
the list goes on
and on so try it totally risk-free if
you don't love it element will give you
your money back
no questions asked they have extremely
low return rates i checked on this
as i was doing due diligence for these
guys long long ago
element came up with a very special
offer for you my dear listeners they've
created tim's club
simply go to drinkelement.com tim that's
drink lmnt.com
tim select subscribe and save and use
promo code
tim's club to get the 30 count box of
element for
only 36 this will be valid for the
lifetime of the subscription
and you can pause it anytime again
that's drink lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club
one more time drink element dot com
slash tim and promo code
tim's club check it out
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
what is vpn virtual private network it's
an app that you run on your computer or
your mobile device it secures your
internet connection
hides your public ip address and lets
you bypass regional restrictions on
content and i actually asked my
followers on twitter 1.5 or 1.6 million
of you
for vpn recommendations your favorites
many wrote back
that expressvpn was their favorite
including a number of people who've been
on this podcast
so i gave it a shot and it is
ridiculously
fast uh to the extent that i thought i
didn't have it on
to give you an idea expressvpn is
consistently rated the fastest vpn
service on the market
it's incredibly easy to use and it's one
two three just download the app tap one
button and you're connected to a secure
vpn
server and i recommend checking out the
website
just to see the sign up flow they make
it really
smooth very easy to sign up
and if you're an entrepreneur or do any
web-based
front-end development or design rather
it's worth checking out for that
alone so expressvpn what are we talking
about here
expressvpn is great for when you need to
get work done while you're on some
sketchy wi-fi network for instance and
i've had
a number of hacker friends of mine show
me how easy it is to snoop on public
wi-fi
just by downloading simple apps you do
not need a computer science background
to do that which scares the hell out of
me
so if you don't want to be a victim of
that you can use
expressvpn or if you're traveling and
need to access something that's only
available in another country
well lickety-split expressvpn has you
covered expressvpn is useful not only
for entrepreneurs
and remote workers and travelers like
yours truly
but really for anyone who wants
protection from being snooped on or
having their personal data
stolen you just use the internet like
you normally would but with
expressvpn encrypting all of your
network traffic to safeguard your data
so check it out visit my special link at
expressvpn.com
tim and you'll get an extra three months
of expressvpn protection for free
that's expressvpn.com tim to claim your
special deal
visit expressvpn.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands
[Music]
organism living tissues
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types to tease
out the habits routines favorite books
and so on
that you can use cereal maybe who knows
morning routines my guest today is
harley finkelstein on twitter at harleyf
harley is an entrepreneur lawyer and the
chief operating officer
that's ceo of shopify he founded his
first company at age 17 while a student
at mcgill
harley is an advisor to felicis ventures
and he is one of the dragons
on cbc's next-gen den in 2017 he
received the canadian angel investor of
the year award
in canada's top 40 under 40 award and in
2016
he was inducted into the order of ottawa
from 2014 to 2017
harley was on the board of the c-100 and
from 2017 to 2020 he was on the board of
directors of the canadian broadcasting
company
cbc in other words twitter harley f
instagram harley harley welcome to the
show
hey tim thanks for having me it's a real
honor to be on the show i
love interviewing my friends because it
gives me an excuse to do a deep dive and
interrogate in a way that would just be
totally
abnormal and maybe sociopathic over
the dinner table and i thought we would
start
with describing or explaining what
shopify is for those who may not know
yeah it's interesting i mean shopify has
obviously grown
considerably over the last couple years
certainly post ipo in 2015.
people read about us more often but i
think most people
know us as an e-commerce provider an
e-commerce platform the place you go to
build an online store
my version though of what shopify is is
really
a bit different than that i think
shopify is the world's first retail
operating system and we can get into
what that means at a deeper level but
fundamentally i think what we do is we
enable anyone that wants to sell a
product to do so
whether that's online or offline or
anywhere else and i think
from a vision perspective where i'd like
us to get to is i want shopify to be the
entrepreneurship company
i i don't think there's been a company
that's ever been created that has been
the entrepreneurship company
and i think we probably have the best
shot at that so that's a bit how i see
shopify
and if we wanted to peg some numbers to
that any kind of stats
or numbers what can you share that would
give people
uh maybe a an infographic of the mind
sort of
an ideal of the scale and scope of what
we're talking about yeah
so we currently have over a million
stores on shopify so a million
businesses a million brands
host their commerce on shopify the
majority of those brands
would self-identify as small businesses
and some of them that were small grew
and to be really really big businesses
the all birds of the world or the bombas
of the world or the gym sharks of the
world or the fashion novas
but for the most part we have a million
stores on the platform and
if you were to pretend for a second or
not a retailer but if you were to
pretend
just for a moment that shopify was a
retailer we would be
the second largest online retailer in
america after amazon
and the reason i mentioned that is
because one of the things that has
happened over the last couple of years
as we've grown and have become for a lot
of people the default
commerce platform we've been able to
aggregate a ton
of these stores to get economies of
scale which we then give to
entrepreneurs and
and help level the playing field and you
and i have spent countless hours talking
about what it means to level the playing
field for
entrepreneurs and in terms of the
company depends on the day you look our
publicly traded company
our market cap is above 100 billion
which still sounds unbelievable to say
and something
is kind of amazing we have about 6 000
employees across 17 offices all over the
world
and in q2 of this year so this past
quarter uh we're talking 2020
our merchants sold about 30 billion
dollars worth of products
on shopify so that's sort of some of the
high level stuff
all right so we're gonna stay on the
present tense for a little bit and then
we're gonna
zoom past tense present tense or i
suppose this encapsulates
any period of time really but what books
have been most formative for you in your
business journey
with shopify and or
what have you gifted the most to other
people what books
yeah um one of the books that
was suggested to me early on in my
shopify journey was high output
management and which is the andy grove
book from uh
who obviously built intel and had done
an amazing job and
one of the reasons that it was
recommended to me was
it seemed to cut through a lot of the bs
of most business books
for better for worse i went to business
school and we can talk about education
stuff i actually found
law school to be 10x more valuable and
instrumental for my
journey as an entrepreneur and running a
big company but i did go to business
school
the business books that they naturally
give out i just
i thought was just full of platitudes
and full of
things that i just didn't find very wise
whereas i found high up and management
to be by far one of the greatest books
and then actually
i think that horowitz is book hard
things about hard things it's almost
like the modern iteration
of high output management as well and
that's been another big part of things
that have been valuable to me in in my
own career
that said uh we are in the middle of a
global pandemic
and one book that i recently reread that
i know you're uh that you know about
is televised book anti-fragile and the
reason i
found it incredibly valuable to reread
it is
it feels like we're in a time of great
breakage
of great change and it feels to me like
what is emerging
through this global pandemic are two
types of people and two types of
entrepreneurs and two types of
individuals which is those that are
resistant
that are kind of waiting for things to
go back to the status quo that are
looking forward and anticipating when
normalcy will return
but then there's this whole other cohort
of people a whole other cohort of
businesses even who are resilient who
are not waiting
for the status quo to return but rather
are thinking about how they can use what
is happening as this incredible catalyst
to change everything and to pivot and to
adapt and the neat part about
anti-fragile is it talks about obviously
the two main systems being robustness
and fragility but then tulip introduces
the third system
of course which is anti-fragile where
things actually get better
stronger as they break like the immune
system for example
and i've just found that to be an
amazing book
for the current time we're living in
right now that you can take two people
in the same circumstances
and one just resist and the other simply
is resilient about it and that book just
encompasses that
in terms of the book that i'm reading
right now is i'm actually reading
this is shocking but i'm reading my
first fiction book ever
i've never read a fiction book in my
whole life i just i haven't i just
wasn't into it
and i know it sounds so crazy but i just
you know it's not where i get i
usually read in order to get smarter or
to understand
a particular thing better whether it's
biographies or it's you know a business
book or just
generally a fascinating book about it an
an interesting true story
and i'm actually reading the alchemist
right now and i i know in this book
you you know well and it's it's amazing
because the relationship that i have
with reading the alchemist
relative to reading a book where i'm
highlighting i'm trying to digest i'm
trying to reflect on it
it's just completely different and it's
actually a lot more enjoyable
actually one of the books that i've
given up the most is it's probably not
the book but
in the early days of shopify i probably
gave out
100 copies of the four hour work week
and and i'm not saying that the flat are
you and i already friends i don't need
to
flatter you but what i would say though
is the reason that book was so important
was because
in 2010 the idea of a side hustle
or the idea of a hobby project that
eventually gets commercialized
was just not in the ether it was just
not in the atmosphere
and this idea that you can actually
build systems
to allow you to run a business
concurrently with doing
anything else you're doing whether
you're in school or you have another job
that was somewhat
foreign and yet i knew that if we
encourage more people to experiment with
side hustles
it would lead to entrepreneurship and
hopefully would eventually lead to them
using shopify so certainly that was uh
that was an important book in in my life
but also in shopify's life
well you've alluded to something we will
spend time on
which is the the current state of
affairs and the future of retail
right because in some ways it seems like
many trends
that may have may have been projected
for 2030 have been
pushed to the front of the line very
very quickly so things have been
compressed so
i want to ask you about the future of
retail but before we do i want to
talk about the past of
shopify and i thought maybe a useful way
to frame that or just a fun way to frame
that would be
number one can you repeat the number of
employees
and market cap of the company right now
depending on the day obviously but
give or take about six thousand i think
we're over six thousand employees and
market cap is
i don't know 100 and something billion
depending on the day i think it's around
120 130 billion
okay and when we first met how many
employees
were there and what was the market cap
so to speak
we first met in sort of mid-2010
we had probably i would say around a
dozen
people at the company total and i think
we had just
either had just raised or about to raise
our series a just about to raise
i think we were just about to razor
series a and i think our series a was i
mean it was sub
50 million i remember the exact number
but it was definitely sub 50 million
so yeah i guess a lot has changed from
our original encounter tim to now
wow yeah i think when you when you put
it in that perspective with that type of
delta it does seem quite incredible
and so i think this is a good time to
just say
and of course i've said this before and
you and i have shared a lot of tacos and
not a small quantity of tequila on
occasion
but i just want to say publicly
that it has been such a joy to
see you and your family and obviously
your your close friends
like toby and so on and the entire team
but since i
know you personally just to see you
do so well has been so fun and such a
joy for me and just like you're not
blowing smoke up my ass you know this
isn't
me blowing smoke up yours although i do
wonder where that expression comes from
but
not losing my train of thought it
couldn't have happened to
just a nicer group of people i
really feel that way and i just want to
congratulate you it's been
it's it's been awesome to watch in the
very literal
sense of awesome so well done i
appreciate you saying that it's um it's
been the journey of a lifetime
and there is not a second that goes by
that i take any of it for granted
i think that part of the story is that
we've built something special and
meaningful and valuable to the world
but also we've done it you know toby
likes to say that we are on a journey
doing difficult things with friends
and i think there's nothing better in
the world of doing things that are
difficult and challenging
with people that you deeply like and you
deeply respect and the cool part about
it is
a lot of the friends we had in the early
days like you for example you're still
part of the story
today i mean you and i talked earlier
today unrelated to this podcast but
something totally different
related to your business and our
business and finding a connection point
and helping each other
that type of community people talk a lot
about
their group of friends or their group of
their community people they spend the
most amount of time with
but there's also sort of a peer group at
a company level i think
that tends to get lost because most
companies as they grow and especially
historically if you study
you know the if you study founders going
back you know 100 years
at some point there is this natural
graduation where
someone decides it's time to bring in
the quote unquote adult supervision or
something like that
and you sort of lose the connection with
the founding story but because for the
most part those of us that are still a
shop like today are still the same group
that
were there in the early days we've
brought each other along with us and
we've brought our friends along with us
also
and it's made for a much richer
experience it's made for a much
more meaningful journey when you do it
with people and you grow
together now obviously the flip side of
that is in order to do that
every single person particularly on the
leadership team has to re-qualify for
their job
every single year and that is
difficult in year one and year two it
becomes incredibly difficult in year ten
year eleven and you know year fifteen
where the stakes the challenges the
opportunities
are all so much bigger but i think for
the most part we've all
focused on re-qualifying for our job and
also keeping our
i i don't want to say modesty but just
staying grounded in this whole thing
and and realizing that you know there is
like we're the same
folks who started who were there at the
beginning and and i don't know
in that way it's just been a really
awesome experience for us
well you guys are still nice canadian
boys maybe it's a canadian thing maybe
the only reason we're nicer because
we're canadian um and uh and i could i
can tell you that there are some
challenges that come with the canadian
thing as well there's a lot of great
advantages there's something called the
tall poppy syndrome here in canada which
is you don't want to grow too tall
because someone's going to chop you down
and and you do feel that from time to
time but for the most part
building a company outside a tech
company outside of silicon valley i
think has been
incredibly valuable to us i'm going to
bookmark a bunch of things here so i'm
going to bookmark outside of silicon
valley because most people do not think
ottawa when they think one of the
largest tech companies in the world for
instance
and then i'm going to bookmark tall
poppy syndrome we
will probably not come back to that so
it's more of a
note for myself but i didn't realize it
was an issue in canada as well it's an
issue throughout the entire commonwealth
right
this is an issue and an expression that
you hear in
new zealand a little bit less so in
australia but certainly tall poppy
syndrome you hear
about quite a lot in places like new
zealand
let's also bookmark re-qualifying for
the job we're going to come back to what
that means
and i'm going to go further back to
law school you said something about law
school now
i'm going to get the pronunciation
incorrect possibly
philip reimer is that his name wow
you've done your research jesus
i have got i've got a full dossier i've
got a full dossier
so who who is philip reimer and why is
why is he relevant
yeah so i was born in montreal in canada
i lived here so i was 13 when i was 13
there was a referendum in canada and
quebec where i lived
where quebec as a province want to
separate from canada
and the referendum never resulted in
a separation of quebec from the rest of
canada but it created
a really tense environment particularly
for anglophones living in quebec
and so when i was 13 my family decided
to move down to south florida
and so i went to high school in south
florida
and then after high school i had apology
for a second sure
absolutely i actually didn't know this
piece of the puzzle how on earth do you
choose south florida
if you've ever been to montreal it's the
most amazing city in the world it's sort
of
you know it's like it feels european
almost but it's in canada which is a
wonderful country
but it's cold as hell and februaries and
montreal are notoriously bad because
it gets dark very very early the number
of sunlight hours is very small
and it's not just february i mean it's
basically january till the end of march
and i think my parents
as they were deciding where they
possibly could move to
i think it was it was going to be
somewhere warm and so it was a
combination of staying on the east coast
est time zone and the fact that we had
some friends and family that had been
living there already and so
they just decided let's go somewhere hot
and so we moved down in this is probably
1996 moved down to south florida
and then after in high school it was
time for me to consider where to go to
college
and my parents didn't have very much
money and so if i were to go to a u.s
school
it would have required me to take out
some sort of student debt but because i
was born in montreal
mcgill university which is a great
school had offered basically me in-state
tuition
and it was like eighteen hundred dollars
a year and there was just
i loved montreal mcgill is a great
school and it was 1800 bucks a year
and so my parents are like you got to go
to mcgill get to mcgill
in september 2001. and
you know 11 days later september 11th
happens
stock market crashes things get really
really bad
my parents lose everything i mean we
lost our house we lost
everything we didn't have a penny to our
name why is that that's because of the
the equity markets yeah my dad my dad
was just over leveraged for the most
part and he was doing things he probably
shouldn't have been doing
and i got it and he just he just did
stuff that that was just highly
correlated to the equity markets doing
well and when the equity markets
fell apart things fell apart for us
and my mom called me and said hey you
got to move back down to florida because
there's no way you can say montreal we
can't give you money we can't you know
we just
just come back down here and and we'll
figure it all out and
i was 17 years old when i started
miguel's i was a bit younger than my
peers
i loved montreal i loved being on my own
and so i basically told my parents hey
i'm gonna stay here
i'm gonna figure this out on my own and
i'm actually gonna also try if i can to
help
the family out as well i have too much
younger sisters so i thought okay i'll
figure this out on my own
and i tried my hand at a bunch of stuff
i worked at a travel agency
i've been a dj since i was a kid so i
dj'd parties and events and weddings and
anything that that and bar mitzvahs
and lots and lots of bar mitzvahs like
300 bar mitzvahs as you know um we've
talked about that a lot um and i dj i
was working in a travel agency trying to
go to mcgill
and it just wasn't working there was no
way for me to make enough money
that i i didn't i can still have a
full-time class load in curriculum
and also help my mom and dad and sisters
and also
pay my bills and stuff and a friend of
mine just was on student council at
mcgill
and said hey just so you know if you're
looking to start a business
one business that is kind of interesting
is that mcgill university
spends like 25 000 every semester
on promotional t-shirts the stuff that
you see at
you know in the in the bookstore the
stuff you get in your orientation bag
that says you know faculty of science or
faculty of arts or whatever it is
hey if you want to start something that
might be an interesting thing to start
and montreal has historically had this
incredible
this sort of they call it the shemata
business but it's basically the apparel
industry you have companies like buffalo
and american apparel
and parasuco and countless other
companies have all been created
from montreal there's a very well-known
and well-developed
clothing business and clothing industry
and i thought okay cool
let me just what was the colloquial name
for it uh
to business which which is this is a
yiddish term that basically means
clothing
um and and and part of it was montreal
was
an absolute immigrant town my family
came to montreal from hungary and 56
but it's an immigrant city and so the
neat part about the apparel industry the
schmatta business was that
it had a low barrier to entry so you can
start a business without with a little
capital
and i had little capital but i had this
one piece of insight
which is mcgill university where i go to
school needs t-shirts every semester
and my feeling was if i presented them
with a compelling
proposal good prices and i was also a
student there
how could they not give me the order and
i spent the next you know two to four
years i guess two years until it sort of
took off and then but four years in
total
selling t-shirts all through undergrad
to almost every university across
canada so it worked well it worked to
some extent it worked that it allowed me
to pay my tuition
it allowed me to help my mom and my my
dad and my siblings
it helped sustain me so i can finish
undergrad
and not have to move to part-time
classes what it didn't do though and
this is where phil reimer enters the
picture
one thing that has been really valuable
to me growing up was i was always able
to have this
this group of mentors in my life and i
know you talk a lot about mentors and
we've talked a lot of mentorship
but i've always had these groups of
people in my life who i just really
admire for totally different reasons
and i've taken this pretty far lindsay
and i got married in 2013
basically six months prior to getting
married
there were three people that just seemed
to have the greatest relationship to
their spouse
and i called them and said hey tell me
about being a great spouse
i did the same thing for being a dad i
did the same thing and a bunch of
different aspects of my life
but when i was starting out in
entrepreneurship at mcgill
one of the people that i contacted was
this guy phil reimer
who was just a friend of my parents who
it turns out wasn't even that close to
my parents but he just
he always seemed to every time i met him
or encountered him we always had these
really interesting conversations about
business
and he would teach me things like the
difference between
the debt side of the equity side of a
balance sheet he would teach me
the idea of investment and taught me
about
equity markets and stocks and he would
explain in just this
very simplistic digestible way and i
just
like i i did throughout my undergrad
years i called phil
towards the end of my undergrad and said
okay i had this little business
it does well i think i'm just gonna
continue building this business and his
insight was
in the same way that you were able to
disrupt a bunch of
existing incumbents selling universities
t-shirts across canada
anyone can disrupt you you do not have
what buffett would call
a moat around the business there is no
competitive advantage here
and so eventually this business will not
become anything
it won't become that big and it's going
to be a grind for you time and time
again because there is nothing that you
have
that is proprietary and there is nothing
that you have that is
special other than the fact that the
people buying t-shirts from you are
students and you're a student so
you kind of have that connection with
them but that that was it
and his his proposal or his idea was
have you thought about going to law
school i was like no i i don't want to
be a lawyer
why the heck would i go to law school
anyways he what he did was he said look
next year i'm teaching
law at the university of ottawa and he's
doing it part-time he's sort of a big
partner to big law firm here in canada
and he said i think law school would be
like finishing school for you it would
be like etiquette school
for you to be a better entrepreneur the
downton
abbey of entrepreneurship yeah like that
it would teach you how to write how to
think critically how to debate
how to argue it would teach you how to
read 4 000 pages and pick out
the one line they call it the the ratio
decided the one line that matters in a
court case
you'd be able to pick that out of 4 000
pages and he convinced me that that
actually
would be an incredible advantage in my
career to become an entrepreneur
and so i applied to one law school on
the advice of this guy phil reimer
and i got in the university of ottawa
and i moved here in
2005. now you i suppose hinted at
what you gained from your law education
what would you
say you mentioned a few things that that
he speculated you would learn
were the most valuable things you
learned those were they other
capabilities or skill sets what were the
main things you took away from that and
i should say also as a side note that
many many successful entrepreneurs have
law degrees but didn't practice law
peter
right chris sacca both billionaires who
have been on the podcast among them that
is
one common thread that shows up now and
again
but what were the most valuable things
in retrospect that you gained from that
experience
are you familiar with the socratic
method have you heard do you know during
that term
i do have some familiarity with with the
socratic method but if you could explain
it if that's going to be
part of the yeah right you've studied
socrates and some of his work so i
assume
there's there's origins there but law
school uses the socratic method which at
least
the iteration of it in the law school
that i went to was they would ask the
professor at the front of the class
would ask a question
and would randomly call out somebody's
name if you answered it correctly
you did well and if you didn't answer
correctly or you weren't present you
would do poorly
attendance mattered which was very
different than my undergrad
and one of the things that this is
so is such a strange takeaway from law
school
but the socratic method made me really
really good at thinking on my toes
it forced me to you couldn't read every
single
piece of assigned work because by the
nature of law school the
a lot of the intention is to overwhelm
you with content and readings and work
so that one you can get ready for the
practice of law in the corporate world i
suppose but also
they wanted you to be able to start
making good decisions about how to
acquire information in the most
effective way the socratic method for me
was incredibly valuable because it meant
that if i was given three cases
to read and one of the cases was 1200
pages and i can't read that in 24 hours
i would have to understand how to get
the information how to acquire the
information in such a way that i could
regurgitate it or i could repeat it if i
was called on
but not know enough about it that if i
didn't get called on
it would prevent me from doing well in
another class who also used
the socratic method and that ability to
quickly
stay on my toes and be ready any moment
to answer a question
in a way that provides the professor
with the information or to substantiate
that i know what i'm talking about
but didn't necessarily require me to
spend all of my time
perpetually studying that actually was
one of the most valuable
things so obviously that and the second
thing is writing
in montreal i went to uh sort of a
jewish private school and in the states
i went to a very large public high
school and it was a really good public
high school
but i you know i got school i went to
mcgill for undergrad and
i had never really learned how to write
really well and i only realized that
in law school i only rose in law school
that i was able to
write a lot but it took me a long time
just to get to the point
and that actually was another major
piece of
it was shaped as a pedagogical learning
but it wasn't actually pedagogy it was
super practical
that it taught me how to very quickly
reply and quickly think of my feet on my
toes but it also taught me how to write
really really well
and for those things alone i wouldn't
change it for anything in the world
which is very very different than i
don't want to sign mbas but i did a
joint law in ba so i also did went to
business school
whereas the mba was entirely case study
based
most of the case studies i felt were not
even you know steeped in any type of
reality
i did not find that to be at all
valuable relative to my law degree
to run a company like shopify today
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs which matches your open
roles with qualified candidates making
it easy to find the right person for
your business
fast when your small business needs to
ramp up for the new year
linkedin jobs will be there ready to
help and getting started is easier than
ever with new features to help you find
qualified candidates
from their active community of
professionals with more than 722
million members worldwide post a job
with targeted screening questions that
will quickly get your role in front of
more
qualified candidates manage job posts
and contact candidates from a single
view
on the familiar linkedin.com website
where functions are streamlined onto one
simple screen
and now you can do all of this from your
mobile device no matter where you are
that's how linkedin jobs can help you
hire the right person
faster visit linkedin.com tim to get
fifty dollars off of your first job post
that's linkedin.com tim to get fifty
dollars off of your first job post
terms and conditions apply
i want to follow up on the socratic
method or acquiring the information that
you need without digesting the
1200 word tone and there are different
aspects to the socratic method so
i'm actually in luck with this
conversation because about a week and a
half ago i read
socrates in 90 minutes which is part of
a series
of books they're very fun very
opinionated
so you have wittgenstein in 90 minutes
plato in 90 minutes and i think they're
somewhere between 10 and 20 of these
volumes and they're
they're very quick to digest as the
titles would imply but
i'm going to read just briefly for folks
a description
of dialectic from wikipedia
and here's here's what it says the
socratic dialogues are a particular form
of dialectic
known as the method of and here you can
probably correct my pronunciation but
alankus
e-l-e-n-c-h-u-s i don't know if that is
from latin or elsewhere literally
refutations or scrutiny whereby a series
of questions clarifies a more precise
statement of a vague belief
logical consequences of that statement
are explored and a contradiction is
discovered so
this is i think a different aspect than
what you're talking about so i'd love to
hear you perhaps give an example of how
you would tackle fixing that
impossibility of reading the 1200 pages
what what approach you might take
but i want to point out for people
listening also if they haven't done any
type of debate
which by the way is something that if
you ever see peter thiel on stage
he will realize he has a lot of training
in
even if he is not able to review a lot
of materials beforehand
and part of how you can be effective in
debate
is by asking people to very clearly
define the words that they're using
very clearly give examples or
definitions
of their positions because most people
come
into battle so to speak if we're talking
about debates
with very unclear assumptions you see
you can effectively
in the realm of debate lead someone to
defeat themselves before you ever
take a counter position if that makes
any sense totally does and actually it's
the best way to defeat them because
then actually it's basically it's
unforced errors
as opposed to forcing them to to make an
error or to make some sort of mistake
the way that it worked at least in my
law school but i think this is the case
in most law schools is
the teacher would ask a question
randomly to a student and say
you know mr finkelstein tell us about
this particular case
and then what he or she would do is they
would ask question after question
which helped them substantiate whether
or not i understood the case itself
so for example hey what's this case
about i would say well this is a tort
case for example and
someone fell on someone else's property
okay well why is this
controversial well the reason is the
property that they fell on wasn't
actually the homeowner's property it was
city property
well okay and and i always tried to kind
of work backwards from
what is the actual thing that the
teacher wants to teach right now
it's not necessarily about the property
it's not about the fall it's not even
about the tort itself
it's about some other thing that the
professor believes will be valuable for
these students to go off with
after this and usually it's something
that is
far more universal and far-reaching than
just well this is how the case ended
and so what i tried to do constantly was
okay this case
you know x versus y here fundamentally
the professor wants to get to the point
where we can have a discussion about
you know city land and so how do i go
from
the overview of the case to a discussion
with cityland
and through that questioning and through
that critical
reasoning and critical debate i was sort
of able to draw
some sort of almost like literally a map
between that initial question to the
final question if i was able to get that
none of the other details really
mattered the problem was
not all teachers were consistent in that
way and some professors
didn't actually think critically about
what the lesson was
not all professors are at the same level
uh some are bad professors frankly at
every school you know you do have
not everyone's gonna be the greatest
professor of law in every single school
and so i'd figured out that this is
where
the professor wants to get to let me
simply reverse engineer the line of
question to get there and if i
knew that i satisfied myself that that
was a sufficient amount of
studying to not get called out or not to
get a bad grade
so let's say that you are designing
a curriculum or giving assignments could
be reading books could be resources
could be
any type of homework assignments for
someone who wants to acquire
some of the most valuable skill sets you
were able to develop
through law school without going to law
school yeah
there's a there's a book called the
elements of style i think that's what
the book is called here yes
yeah it's drunk and white exactly that's
right yeah i mean
frankly everything i learned in in law
school from a writing perspective
the elements of style uh would have
taught me already and i i think
it was written like the 1920s uh yeah
1923.
very small very short book i think it's
like 60 pages or something
for 43 pages 43 pages i mean it's it's
it's
1918. wow yeah so
if i didn't go to law school but i want
to replicate some of those
learnings some of those lessons the
elements of style was a big one that
would be first
the second thing that actually it did
was we had a lot of guest
lecturers in law school and i went to
lawson 2005
youtube was probably around it wasn't
necessarily as popular as it was now
but one of the things that the
professors did and i think a lot of law
schools do have this type of
dynamic where they bring in guest
lecturers
when you bring in someone this is why i
love podcasts so much or
or interviews for that for that matter
so much is because when you bring in
someone who's written a book
and you give him or her an hour of their
time and you ask questions about the
book
you tend to very quickly get to the part
of the book that they
loved writing the most and that tends to
be not always but that tends to be
the the major takeaway and so if there's
12
chapters usually the writer the author
in this case uh legal textbooks the the
legal scholar on the topic
will very quickly get to okay forget all
that here's what i want to talk about
today
and that i think you can replicate
without going to law school simply by
watching
great podcasts and great interviews and
and just really high quality
conversation
and probably the third thing is what you
you sort of said this earlier but
we did moot court m-o-o-t which is
effectively like debate
it's you're pretending like you're in
court there's a judge there's a jury
there's you know there's there's two
sides of a particular argument
and whether it's debate or it's moot
court
that has been instrumental in in my life
and i loved mood court i did quite well
i was able to you know compete with
other schools and and
people in different countries so whether
it's debate or it's moot court or it's
any way that you actually can get into
difficult discussion where the other
party is not only looking
to be right he or she is looking to
prove that you are wrong
man i think that is incredibly
instrumental
yeah for sure to build on a few things
you said so along with the elements of
style there's a great book called on
writing well by william zinser
z-i-n-s-s-e-r it's a classic it's a bit
longer
300 and some odd pages but i found it
incredibly helpful for
removing ambiguity and what
one might call in the legal profession
puffery maybe not in canada but
yeah no no totally that's here too so
puffery i'll give an example
if you have ever bought a shampoo that
says
increase vitality or hair
volumizer these are words that have no
meaning
they can't have a meaning because that
would then be a structure
or function claim and it would require
all sorts of other regulatory hurdles
for an over-the-counter product like
that so or
toning right in the realm of exercise
like that that does not have any
physiological meaning whatsoever and to
help clean up declutter your mind of
these types of words
or any type of bloat these types of
books are super helpful
furthermore one thing you can do and
i've done this before with my own
writing is to ask
friends or to hire someone like a star
law student they don't have to be a
lawyer
to edit your writing
and they could be arbitrary writing
assignments it doesn't matter right make
make it an assignment for yourself if
you have the budget or the access to the
ability
three pages a week you have a three page
assignment every week and you have
someone with
legal training go through it to redline
the [ __ ] out of it
because they will identify anything that
were in a contract let's just say
would immediately get spotted by one
side or the other because
it's unclear right and if you need
something to be
defensible or to withstand scrutiny of
the court
you got to ferret that [ __ ] out right
away yeah interesting
and it's super super helpful it's funny
i'm just reading so stephen king wrote a
review
of elements of style and this is a funny
review that he wrote he said there's
little
or no detectable [ __ ] in that book
of course it's short it's
85 pages much shorter than this one i'll
tell you right now that
every aspiring writer should read
elements of style rule 17
in the chapter titled principle of
composition is omit needless words and i
will try to do that here
that's his entire review of the book
yeah i have another one next to me just
for nerds who want to really go crazy
literally a book that i have with me
today called draft
number four by john mcphee m-c-p-h-e-e
on the writing process which if you
really
are a nerd and want to study structuring
how you structure a piece
that's a really excellent book as well
yeah
before we move on from books real quick
you mentioned the alchemist
paulo cuello so two things on that
number one for people who don't realize
yes that book has sold something like
100 million plus copies in many
languages
it was a complete failure in the
beginning it was rejected
it was pulled from circulation and
paul though has been on the podcast i
want to make one fiction recommendation
to you
and that is dune by frank herbert
and i think it will go right up there
next to the horowitz book and next to
andy grove in terms of maybe not
management but
leadership books i think i think you'll
be very impressed with it
let's come back to your job
what do you do at shopify harley
my official title is chief operating
officer um and
from a sort of divide the world and
conquer perspective
i look after it's more the business side
of shopify the commercial side of the
business
but actually we talked a bit about
earlier about this idea of re-qualifying
for your job
part of that annual requalification that
i'm trying to do each and every year
is to also understand how to add the
most amount of value
and one of the things that i think is
really important the early days of any
company and actually it's
super important as a company ages but
certainly in the early days where you
don't have
6 000 people is to figure out okay what
are the ways i can add value
things that only i can do things that
have the greatest impact things that i
enjoy
doing and the one
common thread or common theme in my i've
been in shopify for more than a decade
and i'm 35 so
like almost a third of my life i've
spent at shop flight which is kind of
crazy but those are the numbers
has been how do i get more people to
understand
what we are doing how do i properly
story tell
why shopify is so damn special and
obviously it's much easier for me to do
that today than it was for me to do in
the early days
although we should talk but build the
business because probably the first
real storytelling opportunity that we
did as a company was build a business
and
you were sort of the co-founder of build
a business we can get to that later but
i would say today
my job is besides the storytelling thing
it's um
bringing on some of the brightest
sharpest humans on the planet to shopify
and then making sure they absolutely
have no roadblocks
or constraints in their way so that they
can do their life's work with us
together that sounds a little bit
mother goosey but that's truly how i
spend my time
that's a great adjective i am going to
use mother goosey in the future
so storytelling storytelling is
important persuading is important that's
another
skill you were able to practice in law
school and
that applies in the build a business
competition which we'll get to
also applies in fundraising also applies
in perhaps telling your own story
to other people you meet along the way
and let's go way back
and i would love to hear you describe
how you first met toby so who is toby
how did you guys first meet and how did
you become involved
with this whole shebang so i mentioned
earlier 2005
i moved to ottawa on advice of of this
guy phil reimer
and when i got here i did not know a
soul i had never even been to ottawa
before
ottawa was the capital of canada it's
kind of between montreal and toronto
which you know
two of the major cities in canada so i
arrive here
and start in law school and i have no
friends i have family here
one of the things that was really
valuable to me in montreal when i was
when i was going to mcgill was
my tribe the people that were sort of my
people my community
people that i hung out with were also
entrepreneurs
and that happened sort of organically
that i just met other entrepreneurs and
we became really good friends and and so
it just worked
and i began to believe that in order for
my for me to find
my my new tribe my new group of people
in ottawa
i needed to figure out where the
entrepreneurs were and
i just called a bunch of random sort of
you know business incubator type
organizations uh one was called invest
ottawa
and i just asked around where the
entrepreneurs um hung out
and someone said there's a group of
entrepreneurs that hang out every friday
night in this coffee shop
uh in ottawa called called bridgehead
and it's like
the parisian poets i guess yeah i mean
it's it's it's far less sophisticated
than that
and certainly far less glamorous but but
i just i was told that these guys hang
out at the coffee shop
and i walk into this coffee shop and
it was a group of five or six people and
some of those people was
you know it was luke levesque created
travelpod who then went
and built messenger kids at facebook he
actually just recently joined shopify
it was sam zade from get around which is
a san francisco startup aiden
mizrahi who did fluid surveys he's now
doing fellow and it was toby
and toby was an immigrant to canada he'd
moved here a couple years prior to that
from germany he moved here because of
fiona he met a girl who's now his wife
and he moved to
to canada and he initially because he
couldn't
work he couldn't get a job someone told
him that without you know without having
your social insurance number in canada
you you couldn't get a job but you could
start a business that entrepreneurship
was a thing that you can do
without having any type of permits to be
living here any type of permanent
residency
and so he sought out to try to sell
snowboards
on the internet built a company called
snowdevil and at the time
this is like 2004 there were two ways to
sell something on the internet
the first way was you paid a million
dollars to some sort of enterprise-y
type of company oracle or ibm
or sap or just these big enterprise
companies and they would do this big
massive
installation for you uh for e-commerce
but it was really expensive
on the other side you could use and sell
your stuff on a marketplace like ebay
or any marketplace that allowed
third-party sellers at the time
and even though that was inexpensive it
effectively meant you're renting
customers
from that marketplace you never actually
own your own set of customers
and so toby being toby and being this
incredible
you know software product genius and i i
say that uh you you
know him so you know that that's
completely different not exaggeration at
all
he didn't like those two options and so
he created a third option
and he wrote this piece of software he
was using a new coding language at the
time was incredibly contemporary called
ruby on rails he was one of the core
members of
ruby on rails and he wrote this piece of
software to sell
these snowboards and he had a really
good you know
snowboard business no devil it was a
really cool business but eventually
as the summer came and people were not
buying snowboards anymore
he had a decision to make either he
would start selling
skateboards or something for the summer
surfboards or
he would take the thing that he had
he had built for snow devil and allow
other people to use it to build their
own online stores
and he decided to do the latter and
focus
on the software side you know like the
snowboards were a good idea but he
really believed the software side of it
was a great idea and he created a
shopify
and this idea was anyone that had
a product to sell was able to use
shopify and very easily set up a
beautiful online store
and i was one of the first people that
used shopify i met him at this coffee
shop i told him that i was looking to
move my t-shirt business from a
wholesale promotional business
which required face-to-face engagement
into more of a virtual business that
would run
while i was sitting in tax law and in my
classes in law school
and i became store 136 i built a little
store called
smoofer uh yep that's true
what the hell is this thing it was it
was it was
it was in the this was sort of the time
like zappos and google
and like a lot of the company names of
that vintage
were kind of made up words right sort of
like the next iteration was the efi
vintage and the next iteration was the
dot io vintage
and but this vintage when i started was
it was just a lot about
finding random words and and the urls
and dot coms were available
so i started this this little t-shirt
business called smoofer um it was a
licensed t-shirt business so
i own the rights to some of the marvel
comics and dc comics and
some of the rock bands uh licensing and
um
and and just started selling these
t-shirts on shopify
and more importantly or equally as
important the same time i really started
to develop this
wonderful friendship with toby he you
know us both really well
he is him and i are polar opposites in
most ways he is cerebral
i am incredibly extroverted he's a
little bit less extroverted i know
you've referred to me as a power
a little bit less considerably less
extroverted than me um
the way that he sees the world is very
different the way i see the world and
in many ways we just we really connected
on
a mutual admiration and mutual love of
entrepreneurship and company building
and commerce but we also enjoyed each
other's
the differences of each other when i was
first setting up smoofer i
wanted him to waive the fees because he
was a friend of mine and i thought he
should waive the fees for shopify
and so i would basically call him every
single week and ask in the way of the
fees
and i think eventually he got so annoyed
that uh he just made my story completely
free
and years later of course when i decided
to join he would say that you know i was
this kind of this this monster and
and he made me his monster um as opposed
to sort of be on the outside
but we became really good friends and
and we throughout law school and
business school we just
i was a shopify merchant i fell in love
with with shopify i thought
how incredibly democratizing it is it
that
me some you know i was probably 22 years
old at the time some punk kid
i didn't have that much money i had
enough that i was able to start a store
but not enough that i was able to
you know do anything meaningful that i
was able to build
a beautiful business while sitting in
tax law class
that was able to compete against the
largest companies on the planet
i mean the other folks that had the
batman dark knight license was
walmart at walmart in canada so i mean
literally i was sitting in tax law class
as a complete nobody and i was competing
against one of the largest companies in
the world
and i was only able to do it because of
this piece of software
this software was just magic to me all
right let me hit pause for a quick
second
we're going to come back to the magic of
the software i want to talk about
how the hell you got the licensing
agreement
if you're selling faculty of law faculty
of this
that and the other thing t-shirts how
did you go about
getting the other license aside from
walmart
to sell these so the licensing world is
really interesting because
what happens is you have what's called a
master licensor who has the rights
and it's not always dc or marvel or even
some big company it's sometimes
maybe based on some sort of legacy or
some sort of yeah like a legacy deal
someone acquired the licenses a long
time ago and has held on to it and
but then you have these things called
sub licenses and what was neat about
that was
there was no way that i was able to
afford the license for any of these
t-shirts or any of these logos
in toronto or vancouver or montreal they
were just too big of a city they were
too expensive
but there were all these not even
secondary cities these sort of tertiary
cities
or tertiary regions where no one had the
license for it no one really wanted the
license for it
and my thinking at the time was one of
the license i did one of the
shirts did really well was was when the
batman dark knight movie first came out
so
i think it's around 2006 or 2007 at this
time i knew that i was able to acquire
for a limited period of time the license
for the dark knight batman
logo which was sort of the new franchise
i was getting a lot of attention and i
knew i was only able to afford to have
that
in particular cities and no one wanted
it so what i tried to do is i tried to
find cities where there was a movie
theater
but there was no shopping mall my
hypothesis
at the time was kids and young people
are going to go out and watch this movie
and they're going to come home
they're going to say hey i want a
t-shirt with dark night on it where am i
going to go to buy it
likely they'll go to google they'll type
in dark knight t-shirt and
i can simply bid on the keyword in that
particular geography
because no one else was doing it at the
time and google adwords was still fairly
new
and it would result in them eventually
coming to my online store
so i did not have the rights to sell
this in any major city and frankly any
city with more than 100 000 people
but i had lots of small areas
geographies across canada
where i was able to sell it to a very
small demographic
and it only lasted like i don't know two
years or so before
some big company came and bought all of
these licenses and i wasn't able to sell
it anyway
but that's that's kind of how i did it
and actually in hindsight i've never
even thought of it in this way but it
was almost like
licensing arbitrage where no one wants
it here but there's value too but no one
actually recognizes the value to it
because they're using
a physical retail business case or
business model for it but if actually if
i'm selling it online then who cares
where they're based
and um and that's that's kind of how it
happened that's amazing
when did you or i should say rather how
when is also pertinent but how did you
end up
joining shopify like what was the
conversation or the email
what what was what was the what was the
actual process
so now you're now you're winding me up
so um after
after after uh after grad school i moved
to toronto so
i think this is how it works in the us
as well but after law school in order to
get call to the bar and officially be a
lawyer
you have to do this thing called
articles uh which is a 10-month program
you have to work at a big law firm or
any law firm for that matter but you
have to work at an accredited law firm
you have to work as an articling student
and then after those 10 months you write
the bar exam and you get called to the
bar and then you're a lawyer
and and that's all that process is
finished i moved to toronto
in 2008 to article at a fairly large law
firm in toronto
and for the first time in my entire life
tim i realized what people were talking
about when they were using expressions
like
a case of the mondays or tgif or living
for the weekend
that my entire life my relationship with
work
whether it was djing or selling t-shirts
or it was sort of you know
hustling through school plus also having
an online store
my relationship with work was always
that of
one great passion but also great love
and great fun
and i just i loved working i i just i
found
it very satisfying and i like the
challenges of it i like the status the
satisfaction
of learning new skills and that all
went away at this law firm whereas
entrepreneurship to me
felt like a true meritocracy law firms
and probably accounting firms too and
some other sort of big companies like
that
or industries like that they're all
probably have this as well
it felt a lot more like it was all about
legacy
they wanted to know who i knew they
wanted to know how many years i'd been
there
because i was a first-year lawyer i was
being given work that was appropriate
for a first-year lawyer
as opposed to being given work based on
my capacity
i was told to do things in a certain way
because that is what articling students
do
and because i was a first-year lawyer
because
i didn't i didn't come from some you
know fancy last name family
i didn't necessarily understand how to
do well in that environment in fact it
completely depressed me
i thought i didn't like what work was
becoming for me i was
my sunday nights were the worst period
of the week i would get this nod in my
stomach
and what i loved about entrepreneurship
was my sunday nights always felt like my
friday nights
and i love that about that saturday
morning or monday morning it all kind of
feels the same
and so probably halfway into the article
so month five or six of
working this law firm i called toby and
said
i really want to join you and at the
time it was it was cody and daniel as
well and i really want to join you guys
and help you build something
big and meaningful and important and it
was mostly you know
toby daniel and cody are three of the
most brilliant humans i've ever met
they're certainly on the technology side
in the r d side and i felt i can come in
and sort of help on the business side
and that was that first call and i think
after i had to meet
our original angel investor was a guy
named john phillips who's still on our
board now
and i had to meet john in toronto for
coffee and had to convince john that i i
was the right person for this and
and i think after you know trying to
convince everyone over
over a matter of months coupled to the
fact that toby had already known me
well both as a friend but also as a
merchant on shop as a customer of
shopify's
in early 2010 i joined the company and i
think my original title was
vp bizdev and legal counsel or general
counsel or something like that
and uh and that was uh that was about 11
years ago
wow seemed like a lifetime ago and we
were talking about storytelling
earlier let's go back to some of the
early fundraising because
fundraising is a dance and the
entrepreneurs
make their pitch and then depending on
the dynamics of the deal how
many investors want in or not
the investors also have to make their
own pitch as to why
they should be part of the deal i'm just
curious to know
if you have we spoke in brief about
one before we began recording that is
how
certain investors were able to get on
your cap table as they call it becoming
part of the sort of equity structure of
of the company do you have any memories
from the
early fundraising days whether it's from
the
shopify side of things from the investor
side of things any particular
any particular items or memories stick
out to you yeah
we decided to raise our series a i guess
around mid or around the summer of 2010
we decided that it was time for us to uh
raise our series a
and that interest or that appetite to
raise some money was based on the fact
that
we began to understand our business not
completely but
at a deeper level than i think we
previously did we understood
what were some of the puts and takes the
company how to spend a dollar here to
make
a dollar 80 on the other side and so
therefore
the more dollars we had on the left side
the more dollar 80s we get on the right
side
we also realized that we were kind of
doing this alone we didn't necessarily
have
too many folks around the table that
understood our business and understood
software as a service as a business
model that understood retail and
commerce
and it just felt like the timing was
right for us to raise around
the first thing we did was we had asked
ourselves
who are we already working with
indirectly whose counsel are we already
taking without even sort of realizing it
and i think around the time maybe a year
earlier best summer venture partners
had written this white paper which i
think is still available online it's
called the 10 laws of sas businesses
and the white paper it was it was great
it was it was
important for a couple reasons one it
gave us the nomenclature
that even today we still run the
business with things like monthly
recurring revenue and rpoo
and customer lifetime value and it
provides us with a set of
calculations and formulas that allowed
us to know whether or not our business
was healthy or not
and just a quick pause just for acronyms
for those who might not know
so sas software as a service service
arpu average revenue per user is that
right yeah getting that right yep
and then customer lifetime value is uh
sltv our customer
customer lifetime value cltv and
it was it was instructive it was it was
valuable so funny enough we were
already kind of working with bessemer
even though bessemer had no idea that we
were doing this
now maybe this is an entire you know
pitch for you you see so much content
coming out from
the investment community whether it's
white papers or blogs or podcasts but
in this case it absolutely worked for us
it was incredibly effective because
it showed us wait a second there is a
venture firm
out there there are a bunch of partners
out there who really understand our
business
at a very deep sophisticated level
and so we knew that bessemer we wanted
best from around and they ended up
leading the series a
but there were two others that i mean a
bunch of other people had heard we were
raising and we got some inbound interest
which was really great
but there were two others in particular
that really kind of set themselves apart
and one i found out earlier today from
you
actually you have a connection too i
didn't actually know this story until
this morning
but at one point in the middle of the
fundraise
in the middle of deciding what the round
is going to look like and who are the
investors going to be and
what the terms of the deal is going to
be like someone showed up
at our door in ottawa we were in this
area called the byward market in ottawa
right above a restaurant
it wasn't a necessary fancy office but
someone showed up
and his name was iden senkit from
felice's
and he showed up and i know now it's
like well i mean if you want to do a
deal you show up but
at the time no one had really ever shown
up at our door certainly not some
well-known highly respected investor
from silicon valley who you know
cut his teeth as an early employee at
google and had this great reputation
but i didn't showed up and part of
i mean once you talk to him you realize
how smart this man is and how
intelligent he is and how experienced he
is
but just him showing up was such a
wonderful him and i talk about the story
all the time now
because it's just a great story but
that's in a nutshell where others would
write an email or
phone you or want to do a you know a
video conference his style is you show
up
and he ended up coming to the series a
which i i think in hope it did
it was a really good investment for him
uh and first mark also first smart
capital from new york
also joined same type of dynamic they
simply
amish at first mark really just showed
up and
helped us the second we encountered them
and that was our series a was a seven
million dollar round
i think it was a 25 million evaluation
uh maybe 25 post
and that was our series a in 2010 so
iden for people wondering is
a-y-d-i-n last name sanket s-e-n-k-u-t
so on twitter he's a sankit and he's an
investor
lots of stuff so you've got shopify
fitbit pluralsight rovio
notion and many many others very
successful
very nice guy yeah also here's a new
story about him in the early days after
he invested
one of the things we needed was we
needed some
we needed a merchant that was going to
sell at scale because we needed to test
the resiliency but also the scalability
of shopify
and iden heard this and immediately
connected us with rovio and so
i don't remember this but angry birds
was just rovio's
major hit is angry birds angry birds was
like flying and i think it was 2011 or
something like that
and the brand i think they were they
were from finland if
i'm not mistaken the brand just blew up
like they had anger brits
cola and they had angry birds clothing
but their plush toys was one of the most
hottest selling items of the season and
hearing that we needed to test the
scalability but also to
show that you can sell at scale and
shopify i didn't connected us directly
with the rovio people and within like a
matter of a week or so
they had launched the angry birds store
on shopify and that really was one of
our first
major blowouts in terms of demonstrating
the scalability of shopify and that type
of investor he is
i have to wonder what his pitch was to
them i'm pretty sure
it wasn't they want to see if their
software would break i can't imagine it
was that
i i assume it was a lot more of hey
these guys are amazing the best platform
ever
they of course they have lots of at
scale stores and so you don't have to
worry about them
but what's interesting was iden had come
to you because of our existing
relationship and you had made the intro
to us from iden and i actually didn't
know that until this morning
yeah it's pretty it's pretty wild and
just to this background context for
people who don't know
toby and i had met in 2009 at something
called a rails conf
you mentioned ruby on rails and for
simplicity let's just call rails conf
developers conference why i was there
was i mean i think i was largely there
as kind of a sideshow curiosity
but that was two years after the four
hour work week
and it had struck a chord in silicon
valley and
rightly or wrongly there i was in the
green room
meaning the backstage room
or a location where speakers kind of
hang out before they go
on stage and that is where toby and i
had our first meaningful conversation
then later
uh was lucky enough to become an advisor
to shopify and so
from that point forward was along for
the ride and
and you actually gave us one of the best
pieces of advice as an advisor i don't
know if you remember
you remember this and i'm gonna i'm
gonna butcher the exact quote you gave
us because i'm sure it was far more
eloquent than what i'm about to say or
articulate but
you said what you guys are building is
great
the problem is that most people that
think about entrepreneurship immediately
think it's either too complicated
or too expensive or too difficult and
that if shopify was going
to be something important in the world
we not only had to build great software
we also had to convince the world to try
their hand in entrepreneurship
and that was one of the biggest piece of
insight certainly in the early days we
ever had received and that came that was
from you and
we're internally grateful for that i
appreciate you saying that the
build a business competition i would
love to know
how you think about it when you're
remembering it because i remember the
conversations very early on
with you with toby i remember walking
past
up and down the sidewalk next to this
thai restaurant in san francisco i
remember exactly where it was
on diamond street in san francisco back
and forth back and forth
past like the bodega on the corner and
having this conversation the very first
conversation about what would later be
the build a business competition but how
would you like to contextualize this for
people because it
is a good example of
a way to differentiate yourself
and generate both attention for brand
purposes
and user sign ups that might be
instructive for folks who are trying to
find a way to stand out from the noise
yeah
are you familiar with the jeffrey moore
book crossing the chasm
yes okay so fundamentally if you were
asking what build a business did for
shopify
it allowed us to cross the chasm from
early adopters that were using it and
this is sort of i mean
the neat part about toby writing the
software in ruby on rails is we got some
early traction
from that ruby on rails crowd and that
was great
but the mainstream had never heard of
shopify had never heard of
of any of us it just it just it was
unknown to them
and so your comment that
hey you guys have the right software for
anyone who has already decided
they want to be an entrepreneur using
shopify is a great idea
but what about people that have not yet
made the decision because
for 99.99 of the world entrepreneurship
is out of reach if you don't know an
entrepreneur if you have never
started a business yourself it does feel
intimidating it does feel
out of reach and through this
conversation
somehow we landed on this idea that what
if we created a competition
as a proverbial kick in the butt to
convince
folks to try entrepreneurship and use
shopify
and the store with the highest sales
would win ten thousand dollars
and i distinctly remember you saying
yeah
that's [ __ ] ten thousand dollars is
nothing you gotta give out a hundred
thousand dollars
which was most certainly more money than
we had
in our accounts certainly more money
than any of us had and combined
like you could have said it a billion
dollars and like it would have been the
same thing to us
that's how much a hundred thousand 000
was um
but this idea that and frankly and i now
realize how much foreshadowing that was
in terms of
the company that we are trying to become
which is the world's entrepreneurship
company
we wanted shopify to be more than a
software company we wanted to create a
movement
we feel that the world is better with
more entrepreneurs how do we get more
people to try their hand in
entrepreneurship
and in the same way you know one of the
amazing
marketing hacks that nike did and this
is i mean they deserve all the cred in
the world for this is
they convinced the world that anyone
that has a body
is an athlete or can be an athlete that
was completely different than
the previous iteration of who wore those
early iterations of nike shoes of
running shoes it was for people that
you know lived in oregon and went to
oregon state and and ran track and field
but they convinced the whole world if
you have a body you are absolutely
an athlete and i think what we began to
do
through this build a business
competition was try
to convince people that if you have
ambition
you can be an entrepreneur and we did
that by virtue of
frankly bribing them to start a business
by offering
a hundred thousand dollar prize to the
store that that sold the most
and it was a very simple competition you
start up on day one
six months later we evaluate who did the
most sales and they got a hundred
thousand dollar check
and what was neat about it was we got a
lot of attention we were in the new york
times and that was a really really big
deal for us at that time
i don't know the headline is offhand but
it's something like a startup creates
their own startup competition
and it was a really meaningful thing for
us and the build-a-business competition
ran for five years after that and
frankly we're now actually thinking
about what the new iteration of it is
for next year but it ran because it
became such a big part of our story
and some of the greatest
direct-to-consumer brands on the planet
were created
through build a business and um so it's
it's a part of our story it seems like
it was just a
campaign but it was so much more than
that it defined us
both internally and externally as a
company that thinks differently about
entrepreneurship
in retrospect and also the time the sort
of the logic behind
pushing for the 100k is
there's psychologically a very big
difference between five figures six
figure and seven
figure and also for those people who are
thinking about how to differentiate
themselves in business or
otherwise but let's just look at it in
the context of entrepreneurship
if let's just say fifty thousand dollars
puts you in the category of i'm using
that arbitrarily but like ten thousand
or fifty thousand dollars puts you in
the category of
business competition and there are other
business competitions that have done
sixty thousand
seventy thousand there is a
day and night binary difference between
that
and being in the category of one which
is the largest
x ever or the first y
ever and sometimes it's really just an
incremental difference
even though at the time it might seem
overwhelming
you pretty quickly realize right it's
kind of like the book i mentioned
earlier
the draft number four until you have a
first draft
the whole thing seems overwhelming and
unwieldy because there's nothing to
refine
but as soon as and i remember this as
soon as
the sort of parameter as a draft became
not could we but what would it look like
to have a hundred thousand dollar
prize and this competition then
you start to find ways to mitigate risk
you start to find ways
to look at it as an expenditure
over time and you realize that it's
certainly not going to be a hundred
thousand dollar loss if it's a failure
and if you shoot high i think it's uh
larry page is fond of saying that
something like this but you know what a
lot of people miss is that if you aim
really high
it's very hard to fail completely right
and
then you guys did it right you had the
new york times coverage and
you were extremely newsworthy right
because you were doing
sort of you had the biggest ambition and
you were also breaking ground as a first
yeah it was ballsy but the thing that
actually is super interesting is that
what you
we didn't necessarily realize at the
time you only have to pay it out at the
end of the competition
so you don't actually need a hundred
thousand dollars when you get started
you just have to be able to acquire
enough revenue over the period of six
months to actually pay that out
eventually and and that was that was
sort of an
uh interesting uh oh right like we don't
actually need the money right now
funny enough there are certain states in
certain canadian provinces
that require you to post a bond
in the amount of the prize in advance i
think you and i've talked about
competition law before
in advance of it so like we actually
couldn't necessarily
offer it everywhere because of some what
they call sort of gaming law but
absolutely it was bold it was ballsy it
was
it was an interesting thing that a small
company was doing
and we had 1300 contestants sign up for
build a business
in 2010 and the winner was a company
called dodocase which made
the most beautiful ipad cases and ended
up you know obama was using one at the
time and he was photographed using his
dodo case and
they also did some really cool stuff
like they completely rejuvenated the
book binding industry which had been
effectively shut down in san francisco
and they they brought these book binders
together and started making ipad cases
but the neat part was the big takeaway
from year one
was some of these businesses were
growing so big
at the hundred thousand dollars or
frankly any amount of money unless it
was something
absurd was not going to be enough of an
incentive
and so as you recall on year two we
changed the pricing to be
once in a lifetime opportunities to be
things that
basically money can't buy and a lot of
that was connecting
the winners with some of the most
interesting people
in the world who were incredibly
generous with their time and and wanted
to kind of help out and we brought on
people like
seth godin and we brought in people like
gary vee we brought on people
like richard branson and tony robbins
and marie forleo and debbie sterling and
and tina eisenberg and we brought these
incredible
mentors aboard and instead of giving a
hundred thousand dollars
we said hey the winner's gonna spend a
week uh with us and a bunch of really
interesting people
on richard branson's private island in
necker and in the bvi's
and i think the last year we did it we
had over ten 000
contestants and we've actually since
then have done a build a bigger business
competition
which is million dollar businesses uh
who can actually grow the fastest
you know 10x 20x and one of the winners
of the last one was
jim shark who as of last week is now a
billion dollar brand
now these businesses may have started
regardless and despite
build a business competition right i
mean ben from jim shark
probably would have started no matter
what but what the competition
fundamentally did was
it provided this catalyst to get started
right now
and that is why i think it was such a
powerful
initiative and movement for shopify and
we are forever grateful to you tim for
really bringing us that because
our trajectory has been forever changed
because of built a business
it's been so much fun and such a
pleasure you know i'd
love to talk about the future of retail
and
you know i'll tell you something i don't
think you know which maybe you do i
don't think so though because we haven't
talked about it
is that i remember when
shopify went public and spending time
there
in new york on wall street and
hanging out with you and everyone's
families and so on
and then not too long after the ipo
realizing that it was a life-changing
sum of money for me
at the time having not lost any
confidence whatsoever
in you guys as a team or a product
but i took my steak off the table and
it's always been this huge source
of guilt and shame for me
and so i was eyes wide open
when in let's say late
march early august i decided to come
back in
and put the shopify jersey back on and
buy back into the company so
i am as bullish as i've ever been
obviously i'm not a registered
investment advisor
blah blah blah i'm not giving investment
advice but i feel
like that sort of psychic load of guilt
and shame
has been lifted which i'm thrilled about
and i'd wonder if you could talk to
to the extent that you can what what has
happened in the last
few months and the future of
retail right like what are the things
that people are missing
what are some of the sort of maybe
assumptions that you have or things
you think are coming down the pike you
have such a unique vantage point because
you're not only seeing
shopify right much like a stripe is not
just seeing
stripe internal finances like they get
to see who is growing
fastest or any payment processor for
that for that matter who is
who is handling this type of stuff so
you get this incredible
perspective on the ecosystem of a
million or a million plus companies not
just
shopify itself if i'm phrasing that in
an intelligible way
so how would you talk to what's
happening what has happened in the last
few months
and the future of retail yeah so first
of all um
you said this earlier but this idea that
the year 2030
has been pulled into 2020 that's a real
thing
and what what i mean by that when i say
it is that
the retail dynamic that would have
existed meaning
percentage of total retail that was done
online laggards that have begun to
digitalize their business
from a commerce perspective that has all
happened rapidly in three months and so
if you look at e-commerce as a
percentage of total retail
when i joined shopify it was
approximately five percent
something like that and last year this
is
these are us numbers last year
e-commerce was about 15
of total retail so we've grown about 10
in like i don't know 10 years
we're now at close to 25
so since march the amount of
acceleration
in shifting total retail to online
retail has been
has been dramatic one is
i'm i'm surprised by how quickly that
happened i'm not surprised where we
ended up because i think we would have
ended up here anyway
two things have happened the first thing
that has happened is
you see two types of entrepreneurs
existing right now i mentioned these
terms earlier but it's worth repeating
you have these resistant retailers and
entrepreneurs and brands
who simply did not adapt and pivot fast
enough and they are suffering i mean
you're seeing iconic brands
whether it's barney's or it's j crew
name your pick that have gone out of
business because frankly they simply
didn't see the future retail coming in
the way that it has materialized so for
example
a lot of these brands that went out of
business they lamented the fact that
their e-commerce efforts was hurting
their offline commerce efforts
which is ridiculous if you talk to any
of the guys at all birds for example
they couldn't care less if you buy it in
store online or on on social media they
just want you to buy their shoes
and their online store may be a catalog
for their offline store or their offline
store maybe a showroom for their online
store
they are completely channel agnostic
they just want you to have a great
experience
and buy a great pair of shoes from them
but a lot of the big brands didn't and
they resisted this change they fought it
but then you have this other category
these resilient retailers we talked
about gymshark earlier in context of
build the business
the day that kovid hit they're based in
the uk
they were told that gyms um where people
work out
were going to be closed they rebranded
their homepage as home shark instead of
gymshark they immediately
changed their content and their
distribution and their influencers and
everything about that company changed
within 24 hours because
the world changed immediately people
were not doing the same thing as they
once were
and you see that across a whole bunch of
different categories
across shopify these great brands that
have just
completely pivoted you've seen you see
restauranteurs that are doing meal
kits and they're turning in their their
restaurants into wine shops if you can't
go in there
you're seeing grocery stores that
historically never even came close to
shopify
it wasn't a vertical of ours are now
signing up for shopify and doing the top
you know 12 most popular items instead
of a beautiful store
chipotle has a store on shopify right
now where they're connecting chipotle
consumers
with the farmers who are there are their
suppliers they're basically creating
a chipotle farmer's market for consumers
on shopify
so on both sides of the coin you see
totally different stories and
i want to focus on the resilient side
because frankly that's the real story
here
the real story is that consumers
generally have now
decided this consumer behavior that they
would prefer to buy products from
independent brands from actual
entrepreneurs
from the makers of the products if they
can
but for a long time the supply wasn't
there so consumers
had to buy through intermediaries well
the cool part about all this is that
the supply side is now caught up so now
you have on the demand side you have
consumers who want to buy directly from
the brands
and now you have the brand selling
direct to the consumer and so you have
this new retail model and and it's not
necessarily just going to be online or
it's going to be offline
the future of retail will likely be
retail everywhere and it's going to be
about consumer preference
which is so different than think of when
you were a kid and you wanted
something you know you wanted a video
game you would be forced to line up
on a saturday morning at some you know
game stop in the mall at nine o'clock in
the morning and the doors open you ran
in to grab the video game and and then
you left
that's how it worked the retailers have
historically always dictated to the
consumer
how when to purchase and what's happened
now is consumers are saying no no
i want to purchase in the way that is
most convenient for me
and a lot of that is online but it's
also offline and it's also across
marketplaces and social media
fundamentally like commerce has been
changed forever
now will the growth rate of ecommerce
continue to grow at this pace
probably not it got pulled forward it'll
probably stay around where it is right
now
but fundamentally consumers who never
bought online before
and have been forced to buy online over
the last three four months
there's no going back to the way it was
there's no way my grandparents
are going to go out in february in
montreal to buy groceries when they know
that they can now use their ipad
to easily buy off one of the grocery
stores online stores
and i actually think this is one of the
most exciting times for retail
of the last i don't know call it 150
years
it is a tale of two worlds and i'm i
hope
some of these resistant retailers begin
to
simply wake up and realize that
everything has changed
and they don't have to be left behind
here's a cool example when you think
about these resilient
retailers you often think of the gym
sharks the fashion novas the bombas the
tommy john underwears like these amazing
incredible iconic
dtc brands but we've seen heinz
ketchup go direct to consumer during the
pandemic we've seen lint chocolate
snickers
shoe and bicycles some of these brands
are brands that i have personally been
calling
for five or ten years to try to convince
them to come onto shopify
to sell direct to consumer and they just
never did it and now
they are because they have no choice so
it's a really interesting time for
retail and commerce
and those brands that have been able to
pivot and adapt they are doing
incredibly well
but there are you know those that simply
haven't made it and i think a lot of
them
were just waiting for things to go back
to the status quo to an old version of
of retail
and i just i don't think it's gonna
happen yeah
i don't i don't think it's gonna revert
to at least what the previous
normal would be anytime soon and
i remember the night that
you know i decided to jump back in to
bed with you guys
and it was very specific a couple of
things that happened a you guys have
been
unfairly well as far as i'm concerned
unfairly punished
in when you suspended guidance and then
the second thing that happened is i
tried to order
coffee filters on amazon and i'm also an
investor in amazon but i had
gone to order some coffee filters and i
couldn't order coffee filters or i could
but
rather than get it through prime in one
to three days it was a three to four
week lead time
because it was not categorized as
essential
which is exactly what amazon should have
done i think
but i thought about it not from the
perspective of
customer inconvenience i thought about
it from the perspective
of cash flow and survivability
from the perspective of the person who's
selling those coffee filters
right you'd mentioned renting customers
and i have friends who run very large
e-commerce brands and small medium and
large
brands everyone would recognize and a
lot of them
have bought amazon stock once they saw
you know a double-digit percentage of
their sales
move to amazon whether they liked it or
not
and to me what that says
is a lot of people having that
experience with the coffee filters
a lot of companies were going to get
caught between a rock and a hard place
where they couldn't email their
customers and say hey
come over to this other store if they
had one
because you'll have to wait a month on
amazon otherwise
and they were dependent on that rented
customer base they couldn't contact
directly and i thought
okay at the very least this is going to
be
a this could be a fatal shot like a head
shot for a lot of companies
but for a lot of them it's going to be a
flesh wound it'll be like a shot in the
leg and they're going to say
holy [ __ ] we at least need at least need
a plan b
so that there is a google discoverable
storefront for our products if this ever
happens again
and that was sort of the assumption that
not to mention the fact that if anybody
this is just sort of me reading stuff on
the internet if anyone from a large tech
perspective
wants to integrate some type
of ecommerce capability there just
aren't that many viable
players so amazon is completely fully
integrated but if you look at
vertically integrated but if you look at
other shops that might only represent
one layer of the stack so to speak right
facebook or whoever it might be their
options are pretty limited i mean they
can build in-house or they can partner
with with someone who's who's already
built out the infrastructure
and the neat part about that is we
actually don't like we don't want to
sell ads right so we don't want to be a
social media platform
we don't necessarily want to be a place
where you're able to scrapbook your
favorite products like pinterest does or
to organize your home furnishings
desires like house or to do any of these
things
the neat part about our positioning is
that we simply want to encourage more
people to
try their hand in entrepreneurship and
to to become
retailers and the idea that to your
point earlier on the pandemic
i think a lot of consumers are thinking
about their local
small businesses and whether we all are
i mean our communities are now becoming
far more important because frankly like
i spend 100 nights on the road in 2019
i'm going to spend you know five nights
on the road
in 2020. my community here in ottawa is
becoming incredibly important so
whenever possible i want to support my
local
stores my local restaurants my local
cafes as much as i possibly can
and one of the things that i think will
remain after this is the importance that
what gives our cities and our towns and
our communities character
are the small businesses but in order
for the small business to survive
in some cases they have razor sharp
margins in other cases they have larger
margins but
we want as consumers to make sure that
our money that we're buying
that the money that we're using to buy
stuff with is going to the people that
actually
are behind those companies that in order
for retail and commerce
to thrive long term it needs to be in
the hands of the many not the few which
is why we talk about this idea of like
shopify wants to arm the rebels we want
anyone that has
some idea some passion some vision to
build something
to be able to do so and to own their
business themselves as opposed to
renting
their business from somebody else and
actually i think one of the great
things that will come out of this is
this consumer trend
to support independent business as much
as possible i don't think that's going
away
after this yeah if it's easy right if
it's if it's easy
and that's that's a super key component
of all this
let me ask you about mentors
and actually mentors in a different
capacity than we've been referring to
them and that is
coaches so it seems like and this is
something i wasn't aware of but that you
have
coaches internal at shopify
available to folks the story i read
talks about cody fauser i guess it is is
that correct
and his experience with coaching but how
do you use coaches and how are coaches
used
at shopify yeah so cody cody was
original cto
and one of the one of the first guys of
the company and certainly someone who's
been a big part of the shopify origin
story
at a particular point he was running
engineering and he realized that his
team was getting bigger and bigger
and he didn't necessarily have all the
tools he needed to be
the right leader but in this sort of
theme and this sort of
lens of of we always requalify for our
jobs every year if we want to keep our
jobs
cody i apologize interrupt but since
this has come up a couple of times what
does it mean to re-qualify for a job
you're getting
effectively hired each year anew
i mean what is it and is that
metaphorical it's more of a loose
philosophical guidance or is it
is there actually a process for
evaluating whether you qualify or don't
qualify what does that mean we think
it's a very valuable
personal growth sort of philosophy that
this idea
and i i can't speak for everyone i
certainly speak for myself and i know
toby uh feels the same way uh in his
role
every single year i still have to be the
best
possible chief operating officer for
shopify and if i'm not
that means that someone else should take
my role and the reason that's important
is because
the pace that shopify is growing at and
has been growing every single year since
since i joined certainly i have to keep
up with it but i also
have to keep outpacing it and so there's
a lot in that i mean shopify again went
from being an e-commerce provider for
small businesses
to being a retail operating system we
have a a billion dollar
capital business we have a fulfillment
business now we're cross-platform
we're publicly traded and so it's a
really really wonderful
model of which to gauge whether or not
you are growing at the pace because
if you say well are you going every year
most people say yes i'm growing i'm
learning new skills every single year
but if i use the lens that if the
greatest chief operating officer in the
world
walked in to meet see the board of
shopify and said hey i want to be your
ceo
i need to know that i am still the right
choice
and this idea of re-qualifying for your
job from a philosophical perspective
has just been incredibly valuable
because it means that
if i grow at the same pace of shopify
still may not necessarily be the right
person for next year
so i have to almost outpace shopify's
growth which puts the onus on me
and all of our leaders to grow this
incredible rate
and whether you call it re-qualification
or you call it you know
disproportionate personal growth that is
something that is baked into the culture
of shopify
unequivocally and it's actually made for
a really interesting
environment to be at because you have
people who so badly want to keep growing
and shopify makes it difficult to keep
up because it grows so fast on its own
as its own entity
but that re-qualification thing i find
is an important for me in my own career
has been incredibly valuable in using as
a bit of a litmus for
my own path i interrupted you you were
talking about cody
so i want to take us back to cody and it
seems like it seems like coaches are one
of the tools and the toolkit for staying
ahead
or front running yeah right
i mean coaching is not anything new i
mean a lot of you know leaders have
coaches but
cody kind of discovered this idea of a
coach and then
he introduced toby and i to it and we
really started getting a lot of value
from it
and at a certain point it became clear
that we wanted to have these coaches
around more often
so we ended up hiring our first coach
his name was cam and and bringing him
out full time and and
he really helped coach the the exact
team at shopify and then really quickly
explain sorry i'm going to keep
interrupting it's my job
what is this coach doing because there
are coaches kind of like teacher right
there are
a million and one different ways to
be a teacher a bad teacher a mediocre
teacher a good teacher or a great
teacher and then there are different
subjects
what did this coach do with you guys
what you're saying is correct which is
that not every coach is the same and
frankly
one of the problems with coaches in
general is that nomenclature that
it doesn't take very much to call
yourself a coach there is no medical
school for coaching i mean you can take
a program or
get a certificate but generally not all
coaches
are going to be the right fit the right
match they're not all going to be of
great value
in fact i initially seen a coach i just
didn't connect with he was a very smart
person i just didn't connect with him
but for cody in particular he needed a
way to scale his ability to manage
a team at scale and so his coach
actually happened to be someone
who ran a very large engineering team at
ibm and that was specifically
the thing he wanted to acquire for me
i'd spent my entire life as we've been
talking about as an entrepreneur doing
everything myself
and i had a real tough time
transitioning from being
this entrepreneur getting deeply into
the weeds doing everything myself
to being really good at hiring and
onboarding and managing people in many
cases that are much smarter
faster more experienced than i was and
so one of the things that
we had figured out was if we were to
bring coaches
into the company full time it would
allow us to provide the coach with a far
more context for what is the coaching
curriculum or the coaching journey that
we all want to go on
that if we only see these coaches one
hour every two weeks
and they don't deeply understand the
shopify culture the shopify company the
people involved
it would put them at a disadvantage for
actually helping us achieve this
development that we were looking for and
so we ended up just hiring this one
particular coach cam full-time and he
was coaching a few of us and and
the epiphany there i suppose was that by
having him
much closer to the business as opposed
to on the periphery
we immediately got far better advice and
and we were able to grow faster
and that eventually led to us saying hey
what if we actually created a team of
coaches at shopify
so that anyone who wants to or frankly
needs to have a coach
can do so and the onus isn't necessarily
on them to find a coach we'll have a
group of coach they can sort of
interview a few of these codes that we
have on staff
but that they work full-time at shopify
and
i don't know eight years later i think
we have over a dozen coaches
on staff at shopify full-time everyone
has their own
coaching curriculum everyone has their
own version of
progress and development with their
coach but by bringing them into the
company it allows them to have a much
richer understanding of the type of
place shopify
is and the type of development that is
required and uh it's been amazing and
and to this day i still see i have a new
coach now
her name is deb and and it's been an
amazing journey for me and in fact
i kind of can't understand i mean i talk
to a lot of
peers who are running companies like
shopify and coaching
as much as i think it's just obvious
that why wouldn't you have a coach
it's not something that is universally
accepted and
i'm not really sure why i think it
harkens back to
the quality assurance and the difficulty
of vetting
in part so let's talk about the just to
give people who
aren't going to be able to hire
full-time because there are a lot of
companies or people who won't be able to
do that but they're
maybe interested in trying coaching what
happens in that hour every two weeks and
it could be
just personal examples but any specifics
would be super helpful right like what
actually happens
is there like a scorecard is there
communication in between
what does it look like and i'm most
interested in
what it looked like before you hired
them i understand the reasons for hiring
them but
at some point you guys thought to
yourselves this is so valuable it could
be even better let's hire them so they
were already demonstrating value what
did the format
or what might the format look like one
thing that that the coaches that i have
seen
have one of the things that they have
done which i found very valuable is uh
they use a metaphor
so for me this is i'll just tell you
what the metaphor is because i think
it's valuable for
for the listeners my metaphor was i
wanted to
develop from a mossad commander who's
always doing everything
all the time and kind of a jack of all
trades
into more of a sensei whereby i can work
with
really really talented people i can
explain to them what destination
they need to get to but in terms of the
journey to get there
i can rely on them i can trust but to
verify i can provide them with some
breadcrumbs to make sure they're going
the right direction
but that inevitably they will get there
on their own
and that may seem like an easy
transition to make it was almost
impossible for me
i found that to be incredibly
challenging simply on the basis that
one i think in the early days i was
really insecure about hiring people
better than me
i thought that if they were better than
me what role was i going to play which
was completely ridiculous
and now i see that and so i had to work
on some of that some sort of personal
issues
i had to work on the fact that this idea
of trust but verify
what do i verify what do i trust you
you've talked to toby about the trust
battery metaphor
at shopify where everyone starts at 50
trust battery and
through their actions we we watch them
hopefully get to 100
which is where they get autonomy but
these metaphors that our coaches use
have been incredibly instructive
so that you don't actually know you know
i i i'm probably still not at the sensei
level yet but i know that directionally
i'm going in the right direction here
and that's not necessarily something
that all coaches use the coaching style
that our coaches use is called the
integral method
which is a bit of a hybrid of a bunch of
different coaching styles
but that metaphor to know where i am
right now to know where i want to get to
and then every two weeks an hourly basis
walking through okay
give me some examples of how you've
demonstrated more of that sensei type
thinking
and less of the mossad commander
thinking holding me accountable to that
when i provide them with something that
is challenging to me
having them workshop with me the right
way to do it
as a sensei as opposed to a massage
commander man that has been so
so helpful it also feels like when you
do bring them in
and i'm not suggesting everyone needs to
hire a coach full-time because actually
i have a lot of friends who have
third-party coaches who just they see
each other every two weeks
the important part that i have seen is
to be really transparent
and incredibly clear about here is the
development i'm looking for
here's what i want to work on if you
just go in
with i want to get better i want to grow
is that a personal thing do you want to
get better in terms of leading do you
want to get better in terms of your
craft
i find the ambiguity that most people
bring into coaching
is not helpful at all and if you were
clear about here's what i want to work
on
here's what i suck at and please you
know
call me out on my on my [ __ ] with
this stuff or hold me accountable to
these things
that i think is where you get the most
successful dynamic with coaches
and frankly you may outgrow your coach
every couple of years it may be time to
get a new coach
who has a different skill set but i i
have to say you know if i had to distill
down one of the things that
allowed me to to get to where i am at
this point with my career and certainly
help me
lead shopify coaching is up there in the
top three or four things that i've done
what else would be up there any others
come to mind that are in the
the sort of 80 20 distillation of things
that have really moved the needle yeah
any other
items come to mind this is a maybe a
personal thing but
even as a kid i always had anxiety i
never had a term for it i never
understood exactly what
what it was i just knew that i had this
thing and
i knew it was anxiety because i was
always thinking about what's next the
future as opposed to
what people often talk about a
depressive state which is looking
backwards i i i was always looking
forward
and i had experimented with some
mindfulness practices and some
meditation in the past
but because i was anxious um in general
i was
anxious about meditating meaning i was
always looking for some sort of quick
fix
that if after 10 minutes of meditating i
didn't find enlightenment
i thought it was broken i thought it
wasn't working for me and
which sounds absolutely ridiculous right
of course but meditation has also been
something that i've committed to or last
probably since 2014 so going on six
years now every single morning
it's either 10 or 15 minutes depending
how much time i have and
it has made me i'm by no means as you
can hear from the tone my voice i'm by
no means
laid back or a chill kind of person
quote unquote
but it has made me more thoughtful about
how i want to expend my energy
and it has allowed me to focus on the
things that are most important both on
my personal life but also with our
business and man like i i mean i know
you talk a lot about mindfulness
practices and and meditation on the
podcast but
i am someone who for years just just did
not subscribe to it and it was because i
was looking for some sort of
quick fix and never came and once i
began to think more
long-term about it to be patient with it
everything changed
and it's been wonderful for me
meditation is a lot like sports in the
sense that
there are many different flavors right
there's like badminton there's curling
of course not to be forgotten thank you
there
because it's hockey too you've got mma
you've got hockey you've got all sorts
of different sports
darts and meditation similarly has many
many many different
approaches what do your sessions look
like do you use an
app do you use transcendental meditation
do you use
open awareness what flavor of meditation
do you use
most consistently so it's funny i had
been historically using
uh just insight timer and just doing
like a 50 minute counter
with a little bit of white noise uh to
block out whatever is happening around
me
but going back to my power
extrovertedness
i have found that this pandemic has been
kind of lonely for me
and i don't mean that in a severe way
like you know i'm home now with my
amazing wife and my two amazing kids and
and
i have my family around me but there's a
certain
lack of social interaction that is
missing from me
and so early in march for the first time
ever i ended up just going to the guided
meditation
tab in insight timer just because i kind
of just wanted to hear someone else's
voice
and i've actually been doing these
guided meditations almost consistently
since march now and they range from
courses i know you mentioned i know
you've talked about jack cornfield
uh sharon salzberg david gandelman
there's some just trying to look at who
else
sarah blondon there's just some amazing
um guided meditation coaches
on insider frankly i mean you can
probably do it on youtube as well
and i actually have found that guided
has been it's like a warm hug for me in
the morning where i hear this really
wonderful calm voice taking me through a
10 or 15 minute sit
and i always end up on the other side so
much better um and so
i started with counting breaths i'm now
trying to do a little more mantra based
tm style stuff but the truth is it
really depends on the day and and
i'm trying not to be too hard on myself
about that experience that if if on a
monday
i had this great sit and i come out
completely mindful and relaxed and
focused
on tuesday if i don't have that same
experience i don't want to
forgo wednesday and the way that i'm
able to have consistency
is just to just take it easier on myself
around
my own version of what a successful sit
looks like
and i think today a successful sit for
me is really just the ability to sit for
15 minutes consistently every single day
no matter what
i feel afterwards it's a very important
point and i'm by no means a mindfulness
expert but it's the consistency and i
think
blocking out that time that
is the prerequisite for almost
everything that follows because by
blocking out that time especially if
you've operated in sixth gear for a very
long time which
you and i both have it's very easy
to try to cram as
much as possible into your waking hours
it's
easy to do and it's a compulsion as much
as it as it is anything else and
by blocking out 10 15 20 minutes to do
nothing
you build in i think a sense of luxury
in so much as you are not rushing
yourself and that has
many downstream effects even if you're
just like thinking about your to-do list
and staring at the ceiling
you're sitting there and you're not on a
keyboard you're not staring at a screen
you're not checking your phone
yeah i totally agree which is one
actually one other thing that has been
very valuable to me is is the
the value of scheduling and being
fairly meticulous about my calendar this
is going to sound totally lame
but you know i have family time blocked
out on my calendar i have walks with my
wife
blocked out on my calendar which again
sounds completely lame and unnecessary
but what it does do is is
that pop-up comes up on the right hand
you know right top right screen
of the side of my screen and suggests
hey like it's family time or hey it's a
walk you know
my wife lindsay who you know is also an
entrepreneur we're just we're very busy
we have two little kids and like
so scheduling a walk together as
ridiculous and silly as it sounds
is incredibly valuable because also if
we don't take that walk it's staring
ourselves
in the face that we skipped this walk to
do something else
so the question is was the thing we
skipped that walk for
as valuable as the walk would have been
and the answer is most times
no they're not so actually being
meticulous with our calendars and our
schedules
especially with two entrepreneurs in the
house and two younger kids
that has been amazingly valuable to us
i could not agree more and only in the
last six to nine months
have have i been using with my
girlfriend a shared calendar just for
the two years
yeah and it has been such a stress
reliever
because she is also an entrepreneur and
if you
somehow at least in my case delude
yourself into thinking that you're gonna
figure it out when you get there
it's it's probably gonna slip through
your fingers
and having it in the calendar just
prevents forgetting and then overbooking
or
fill in the blank with half a dozen
things or a dozen or a thousand things
that could
crowd out that recovery time and that
family time and these various
self-care practices that are so
important for everything else to work
smoothly
just a couple more questions for you and
then we can can bring this round one
to a close i'm curious what contemporary
ceos or ceos sort of c-suite execs
do you most admire or admire greatly
if that takes the pressure off a little
bit i'm just wondering what modern day
current day folks do you look at and say
that's someone who i'd like to i could i
could emulate a little bit or that's
someone i could learn from or that's a
good person to watch
etc yeah i mean there's some obvious
ones i i think
one of the cool parts of of being in my
position this is a new thing for me but
one of the cool parts is using my email
address
if there's someone interesting i can
actually get in touch with them that was
that's brand new to me i'm
that's not a that's not a flex or some
sort of humble brag
that was never the case i mean i i would
send out emails
100 emails a day sometimes in the early
days to connect with different
executives and leaders just to pick
their brain just to get to know them
better
and most of the time they never
responded and one of the great things
now that i really do not take for
granted i'm really
fortunate to have is that i usually get
a reply back which
is is so damn cool and so i've thought a
lot about that the truth is a lot of the
people that i admire i i sort of admire
from i admire from afar like bob iger
i've never met bob iger i just i think
he's
incredible or phil knight i think these
are incredible humans but there are some
companies that i think
are just run by people that i i really
like i really think are doing it for all
the right reasons
a lot of them are people that are in
kind of the shopify ecosystem people we
work with
you know obviously we were quite close
to the folks at stripe you mentioned
them earlier
patrick and john i mean they are they're
absolutely driven to
do incredible things but also build an
incredible company
i i think ben and pinterest is doing an
amazing job as well in that way
a lot of the people that i really look
up to though are not necessarily in tech
per se
it's people that i just think you know
one of the people that i really like is
a mutual friend
i love talking to chase jarvis i know
you chased a good friend of yours as
well every time i talked to chase
i learned something completely new or
damon john when i was also a mutual
friend
these i mean damon built fubu he didn't
build a tech company but every time i
talked to him about something unique and
different
he tells me a story an anecdote about
how we got his shirt on ll cool j for a
music video and it just
from these what seems like random
stories and anecdotes i'm able to find
such great value and such great
motivation to think about things in a
completely different way but
is there someone in particular that i'm
trying to emulate entirely not not
really i'm trying to
before i have uh i had bailey or our
four-year-old daughter
i wanted to talk to people that i really
felt were great great dads and great
parents
or someone who was a great spouse before
i got married i'm trying as much as
possible to take a bit of an approach
that i can have
as many mentors as i can handle and i
can pick one thing from each of them
the interesting part is when you find
people that are really really good at
one particular
thing they tend to be fairly spiky
meaning they may have an incredible
strength but also have a whole bunch of
weaknesses
and so the model that i'm trying to
create now with mentors and advisors and
people in my life
are to take something special from each
particular person
and use that in my own day-to-day i try
to be a bit of a generalist as much as
possible as opposed to
specialize in one thing i think that
there's a little bit of a
anti-generalist theme right now
certainly in silicon valley but
i don't purport to be well-rounded but i
am trying to be well-rounded with the
stuff that really matters to me
whether it's leading whether it's the
business whether it's inspiring
the future entrepreneurs of the world or
it's about i'll give you a quick story
we have this new show that we just
launched on discovery called i quit
and it was a studio called shopify
studios with the single mandate to
create the most inspiring and authentic
content
about entrepreneurship in the world and
you'll never hear us mention shopify on
the show because that's not what it's
about
it's about entrepreneurship and before i
got on the show i
sat down with damon and said walk me
through what it's like to be on a show
like shark tank and
how do you show up and how do you
prepare and what kind of advice do you
give which is digestible
but also doesn't come off as overly
obvious that's the
way that i tend to do things when
there's something that i want to get
really really good at
i'll find the three or four people who
may not be the obvious
experts in it but i understand there's
an angle to them that i really want to
emulate
and then i'll just ask them and uh it's
pretty cool that i i can do that now
that was something that for those of you
listening that that do
email 100 people and you're always
trying to get more advice and you're
always trying to find
someone who will give you some of their
time or quote unquote so you can pick
their brain
the neat part about doing that is if you
send out enough of those you eventually
get a yes and that's how i connected
with you and that's how i connected with
seth who's a big part of my life
and it was just this is before anyone
even heard of shopify it's been a really
important part of my life
seth is amazing seth gooden for people
who are curious
i'll also just want to say as a public
service announcement
that the success rate with may i take
you to coffee and pick your brain is
probably pretty low
there's a there is a uh what you might
consider doing
is a bunch of free work for somebody and
just sending it to them
and that's actually how i've ended up
hiring a bunch of people i'm not saying
do that to me by the way because i'm not
planning on hiring more folks but if
people look up the name
charlie hohn h-o-e-h-n
and my name he's written about the
experience
that we had he also wrote about the
four-hour body launch that's called
interested in that yeah one thing that
i've always found valuable in especially
in the early days of shopify was
if i want to connect with someone who i
knew was incredibly busy and there's
the likelihood of them responding was
very very low i would figure out what is
the thing that is most important to them
right then and in the case of you know
let's say it's an author obviously they
have a book release coming up
i would figure out how i can be valuable
to them so asking someone
i live in name some random city i want
to host
a book reading or a chapter reading in
my community and i'll buy 30 books or 50
books
even if it's not 3 000 books i find that
if you can add some value to something
that is so damn important to them right
then and there
and with social media it's easy to
figure out who cares about what at what
time
man is that an effective way to to spend
some time yeah totally
and there's a book called the third door
i would recommend people check out as
well which has some very funny stories
and very effective advice
in it which is about taking the path
less traveled when it
comes to contacts of that type harley
let me ask you
because we're talking about these
various leaders are there any
biographies
that you i don't know if you read
biographies but are there any
biographies
that you've read and found particularly
impactful or influential yeah
i'm not sure it's a biography but one of
the best books i i've read and i read it
a couple years ago
is is shoe dog i'm not sure if have you
read chew dog i have it sitting i was
sent a copy
a hardcover i like using kindle because
i take notes a lot or highlights but i
have not read it yet it's been
recommended many times
it is it is awesome it's awesome for
anyone who wants to who's building a
company anyone's an entrepreneur or
frankly anyone who's just
interested in the idea of ambition one
of the reasons that
i have fallen in love with
entrepreneurship and one of the reasons
that i've dedicated my life to
creating more entrepreneurs with shopify
as the vehicle to do so
is because i'm i'm fascinated with
ambition i'm fascinated with how people
find ambition keep ambition increase
ambition and unfortunately
lose ambition and the story of shoe dog
and how phil knight
was so determined i just i think it was
it's such an amazing story and the cool
part about it is
i think because phil is where he is
right now and and has really not
approved anyone anymore he was able to
be incredibly candid
one of the problems i find particularly
about autobiographies is that
you end up seeing sort of the highlight
reel of people's lives especially people
that are not sort of at the end of their
life or close to the end of their life
where they feel
like they still have to flex a little
bit they still have to kind of show off
about how great they are
what i love about shoe dog is there's
this incredible modesty and humbleness
about the story which is
this was not pretty and there were like
12 different
opportunities for this whole nike thing
to fall apart and he goes into the
details and tells the stories that i
don't know i found it to be
so fascinating it's a great book and you
can get through it in like five days if
you're interested in it because it's
just
you can't put it down but that's
probably the best one that i've read
recently
on that topic i have to read it and i'll
tell you why which which is not a reason
that
most people would probably cite and it
and that is that it's
it was written we could say co-written
but in reality written by
one of my favorite authors whose name
people will not recognize
and that is j r morringer so he is the
collaborator so to speak who
wrote phil knight's memoir shoe dog and
for people who want to look him up you
can find him on wikipedia j r morringer
m-o-e-h-r-i-n-g-e-r john joseph
j.r moringer and i came to know him
because even as a non-tennis player i
read
open which is the autobiography
yeah andre agassi and it blew my mind it
was
so good so engrossing you're the third
person to recommend that to me i've
actually i love tennis i play tennis but
i have not read that i'm actually gonna
write that down too
so now you know it's it was in effect
written by the same person that's cool
and for that reason alone that's cool
he can't believe that
he did so jr moringer won the pulitzer
prize for newspaper feature writing in
2000 also he's a hell of a writer yeah
if i could if i could collaborate with
with anyone on that side of things
he's at the very very top of the list
he's so good
just incredibly incredibly not just
gifted but talented
in a way that you know in a fashion that
you know is the
output of hundreds of thousands of hours
of refinement in practice if that makes
sense that's cool
shoe dog it's on the list we'll swap
since
i've read open uh but have not read
shoe dog harley is there anything else
that you would
like to say any closing comments any
thing at all that you would like to add
before we wrap up for for this round one
probably the full circle comment is that
you and i are sitting here
sort of midway through the year a little
past that 2020.
one of the things that we talked about
mentorship on this in the last hour so
we've talked about
people in our lives that have helped us
and and certainly we've talked a lot
about entrepreneurship
but one of the biggest things for for us
in our story is having
not really mentors not necessarily
advisors but people along
for the ride that are our fans our
supporters are
catalysts for those days that are
challenging
and i remember this particular moment
um we were it was it was in 2015 it was
may 2015 we were at the new york stock
exchange
we were about to take the company public
and remember looking down and
our families were there and you were
there as well at the stock exchange
and i remember thinking what an
incredible journey it's been
not just for shopify but also to have
people like you tim
in our lives helping to support us
helping to lift us up when
we thought things were a little bit
tough and we weren't necessarily sure
what direction to go into
i don't know if there's a term for that
maybe it's just friend maybe maybe it's
just a supporter but
for those listening you find these
people throughout your own journeys
whether personal or professional
that in some ways will change the
trajectory of where you're going
that there may not be a term for it it
may not be obvious where you're going to
meet them like a green room at some
tech conference like like railsconf in
your case
but these are the people in the story
that are super valuable to have and and
i just i want to say just for a moment
of gushiness or of emotion for a second
that it's just it's been an incredible
honor and privilege to have you
as one of our supporters the entire time
and certainly the last decade or so tim
it's been amazing for us and anyone out
there
find your group of supporters however
you can it changes everything
it allows you to it enables you to do
things that you can otherwise do whether
it's
i'm gonna give away ten thousand dollars
for a competition and that supporter
says no that's stupid give away a
hundred thousand dollars
they push you to be better they see a
better version of yourself than you see
and i think those are the people that
they help make magic
and and you certainly have been that for
us and i'm just i'm very grateful for
that
thank you so much harley it's uh i wish
you could see my
my smile right now i've i've had
such an incredible journey
with you and toby and the gang
and i view you as a brother i have a lot
of love for
you and your family which i hope is
super clear and has been super clear
and i view you as a companion on the
path
you know that's a good i like that term
that's a good one companion on the path
that's a nice one
that's how i look at it and it's that
companionship and camaraderie is rare
it is rare and not everyone you spend a
lot of time with
not everyone you know for a long time
will fit that description
[Music]
necessarily at least with the sentiment
uh with which i intend it
but those people those companions in
many ways they are the difference makers
they are the ones that it's not even
those that that raise the bar for you
although they certainly play that role
too but
we have a few people not very many but
we have a few people who have been these
companions on our journey with us
and i'm not sure we'd be here without
those companions
so i don't know how you're going to find
those companions i'm not suggesting
that you show up at tech conferences and
go to the green room and try to find
find them
but i i am suggesting that when you do
find them that you marinate that
relationship that you work on it that
you
continuously leverage and connect with
them to say hey i'm thinking about this
other thing
i mean like i said earlier as early as
this morning i pinged you on something
totally different about some development
thing we're doing at shopify on the
leadership side and got your advice
use that stuff because i think as much
as i get value from it
at least from my perspective you seem to
really enjoy also providing that context
and that advice
and it's just it's just this amazing
thing that you can find and it's just
you don't hear about these stories very
much because everyone wants to
frankly pattern match of oh that's a
mentor oh that's an advisor that's a
board member that's a friend
but there's this other thing which is a
hybrid of all those things
that is so freaking powerful yeah i
couldn't agree more and i also want to
really emphasize something for people
who are listening to this conversation
and that is the expression you know nice
guys finish last
is not a truism it is
absolutely not required that you become
a ruthless predator to win in
the game of business and certainly in
the game of life that
backfires more often than not and i
really view
you toby and others as exemplars
of the opposite which is
leading with a kindness and of course
you're going to be effective competitors
i'm not trying to imply that you're
going to let people steamroll you in any
capacity because you guys are very good
at short and long term planning but
what really sticks out to me that may
not be obvious from the conversation
is that you guys are incredibly generous
in spirit so you have helped
many many many many many people you've
reached out and
offered to help many many many many
people
without any expectation of a payback
without any tit-for-tat expectation does
that make sense totally
it it it does and and actually because
we are playing the long game we want
shopify to be a hundred year company
and we ourselves want to be doing this
for a very very long time
and if you use a lens of a very long
term perspective whether it's 100 years
or 50 years
you begin to reinterpret and re-evaluate
how you engage with people you begin to
think about things in totally different
terms
even if i'm not going to get an
immediate roi next year who cares
if i can help someone now who eventually
may or may not want to help me back
later on
that's good enough but i absolutely
agree with you this this connotation or
this this idea that
you have to doggy dog is the way to win
i don't think that's the case in fact i
would actually say entrepreneurship is
the opposite of that
the cool part about entrepreneurship is
the more entrepreneurs that you
that you help the more people that want
to help you it creates this incredible
virtuous cycle
and that's where things get really
really that's the flywheel that's that's
where stuff gets really good
yeah absolutely and people can check out
finite and infinite games by cars as is
also a good meditation on a lot of this
stuff
harley always so much fun this was at
the very
at the very least a good excuse just to
catch up and jam and
talk for a couple of hours and people
can find you on twitter
harley f instagram harley website
harleyf.com
obviously shopify.com and we'll link to
the build of business and past videos of
the uh trip to fiji and gatsby castle
all this craziness
oh yeah yeah that was a fun one yeah
which people will get a real kick
that's really cool timbo thank you for
this i really enjoyed catching up as
well
and hopefully for your listeners they
got some value from this but this was
this is really fun
absolutely and i hope i hope we are
hanging out 50 years hence
i'll keep eating my veggies and fasting
on occasion to try to keep me standing
for that long but it's really fun to
have companions
on the path so thank you for being one
thanks tim
and to everybody listening we will have
show notes as always links to everything
that we have discussed
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
just search
harley and it will pop right up and
until next time
thank you for listening just a few
important disclaimers
i own stock and shopify i became an
advisor to shopify way back in the day
when they had something like 10 or 12
certainly fewer than 20
employees i was not compensated in any
way to have shopify represented on
this program or to talk about my reasons
for investing in shopify
of course i am a big fan i may benefit
financially if shopify stock goes up in
value but i'm not an investment advisor
all opinions are mine alone
there are risks involved in placing an
investment in any company none of the
information presented today
is intended to form the basis of any
offer recommendation or of any regard to
the investment objectives
financial situation or needs of any
specific person i think that
pretty much covers it so you got it all
right
thanks for listening folks hey guys this
is tim again just a few more things
before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
expressvpn what is vpn
virtual private network it's an app that
you run on your computer or your mobile
device it secures your internet
connection
hides your public ip address and lets
you bypass regional restrictions on
content and i actually asked my
followers on twitter 1.5 or 1.6 million
of you
for vpn recommendations your favorites
many wrote back
that expressvpn was their favorite
including a number of people who've been
on this podcast
so i gave it a shot and it is
ridiculously
fast uh to the extent that i thought i
didn't have it on
to give you an idea expressvpn is
consistently rated the fastest vpn
service on the market
it's incredibly easy to use and it's one
two three just download the app tap one
button and you're connected to a secure
vpn
server and i recommend checking out the
website
just to see the sign up flow they make
it really
smooth very easy to sign up
and if you're an entrepreneur or do any
web-based
front-end development or design rather
it's worth checking out for that alone
so expressvpn what are we talking about
here expressvpn is great for when you
need to get
work done while you're on some sketchy
wi-fi network for instance and i've had
a number of hacker friends of mine show
me how easy it is to snoop on public
wi-fi
just by downloading simple apps you do
not need a computer science background
to do that which scares the hell out of
me
so if you don't want to be a victim of
that you can use
expressvpn or if you're traveling and
need to access something that's only
available in another country well
lickety-split expressvpn has you covered
expressvpn is useful not only for
entrepreneurs and remote workers
and travelers like yours truly but
really for anyone who wants protection
from being snooped on or having their
personal data
stolen you just use the internet like
you normally would but with expressvpn
encrypting all of your network traffic
to safeguard your data
so check it out visit my special link at
expressvpn.com
tim and you'll get an extra three months
of expressvpn protection for free
that's expressvpn.com tim to claim your
special deal
visit expressvpn.com tip
this episode is brought to you by
element that's spelled lmnt
what is element it's a delicious
sugar-free electrolyte drink mix i've
stocked up on boxes and boxes this stuff
i have an entire shelf in my garage full
of these boxes and i usually use
one to two per day element is formulated
to help anyone with their electrolyte
needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following a keto low carb or paleo
diet if you've ever struggled to feel
good on these diets
it's most likely because even if you're
consciously consuming some electrolytes
you may not be getting enough
electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger
cramps headaches tiredness dizziness
this is where elements can really help
and now with the winter months ahead of
us it's important to know that sweat
evaporates much more quickly in cold dry
weather
misleading our bodies into thinking that
we aren't losing fluids and electrolytes
as a result our thirst response can
decrease up to 40 percent
this response means that our kidneys
don't receive the signals they need
from hormones to conserve water instead
causing our urine production to increase
electrolytes are crucial to supporting
anti-diuretic hormone
adh also known as vasopressin vaso
this hormone helps us to get through the
night with minimal
and the fewest number of bathroom breaks
improving sleep quality going to sleep
dehydrated
is a recipe for poor sleep quality to
make it easier for you guys to stay
hydrated in the winter
element has developed a versatile new
flavor chocolate salt chocolate salt can
be enjoyed cool
like elements other tasty flavors citrus
salt is probably my favorite
but it's especially delicious when
served hot weather with water or even
milk
just like you would with a cup of hot
cocoa or tea i like adding it to my
coffee in the morning so i have a small
amount of cream could be coconut cream
could be some other type of cream
coffee and then i'll add in the element
usually to
at least 16 to 20 ounces of coffee
so that's a good amount that i can kind
of sip on throughout the morning
sugar artificial ingredients coloring
all that nonsense are unhealthy and
unneeded there's none of that stuff in
element who uses zelda
here just a few three navy seal teams as
prescribed by their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl teams have subscriptions as
well as many nba players and coaches
element is the executive hydration
partner of team usa weightlifting
and the list goes on and on so try it
totally risk-free if you don't
love it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely
low return rates i checked on this as i
was doing
due diligence for these guys long long
ago element came up with a very special
offer for you my dear listeners they've
created tim's club
simply go to drink element dot com slash
tim that's drink lmnt.com
tim select subscribe and save and use
promo code
tim's club to get the 30 count box of
element for only 36 dollars this will be
valid for the lifetime of the
subscription
and you can pause it anytime again
that's drink lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club
one more time drinkelement.com tim and
promo code
tim's club check it out
you